Ich nie san sie. Ich nie san xie.
Ich höre Stimmen.
Ich auch, muss am Rang liegen.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, ihr habt Chaosradio Nummer 59 auf Fritz eingeschaltet. Heute, ja, jetzt Chaosradio, jetzt neu, heute mit drei Moderatoren mehr. Also der CCC ist in mein kleines bescheidenes Studio gekommen mit ganz, ganz vielen Menschen, die alle gleichzeitig reden wollen. Das ist mein Problem nicht. Gebt euch mal, gesagt mal hallo. So, ein paar Mikrofone habe ich verteilt. Andreas, Ed Andreas Org hat ein Mikrofon.
Schönen guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend. Ihr habt einen Namen? Erdgeist. Was? Erdgeist? Erdgeist hat ein Mikrofon und Genja hat ein Mikrofon. Hallo. Hallo. Wollen wir erst Musik hören oder wollen wir erst sagen, worüber wir reden wollen?
Naja, wir können ja schon mal erzählen, was es gibt heute. Es geht nämlich um PDAs. PDA steht für Peridural Anästhesie, nein für Personal Digital Assistant. Und es geht im ganz Allgemeinen um Computer, die klein genug sind, dass man sie in einer Hosentasche oder vielleicht auch in einer Manteltasche, wenn man über ausreichend große Mäntel verfügt, herumtragen kann und die keine beweglichen Teile haben, weil bewegliche Teile böse sind.
Bewegliche Teile sind böse, ja.
Bewegliche Teile sind ganz böse. Das sind diese kleinen schwarzen Dinger, die man dafür machen, dass sie nicht funktioniert.
Das ist das, was beim Erdgeist von irren Blick sorgt. Bewegliche Teile. Da ist überall bewegliche Teile drin.
Genau. Und wir werden mal ein bisschen den aktuellen Markt, die aktuelle Marktlage beleuchten, was es so für Hardware gibt, was es für Betriebssysteme gibt, was es für Anwendungen gibt, was für Anwendungen denkbar sind und wo sich das alles entwickelt.
Ja, es tut mir leid, aber ich hab hier eingestellt und es ging nicht. Andreas, sag du doch mal was.
Was soll ich denn sagen, dass irgendwie Technik scheiße ist und...
Technik ist scheiße, genau. Ja. Jetzt sag doch mal was. Reden wir doch über PDAs.
Reden wir über PDAs. Nee, jetzt haben wir wieder Musik. Aber jetzt können wir auch über PDAs reden. Was habt ihr denn so für PDAs? Also ich hatte meinen Pilot und der ist kaputt gegangen, seitdem hab ich keinen mehr und ich warte darauf, dass es taugliche Geräte gibt.
Soll ich mal posen? Der Mensch, der am wenigsten Ahnung von Rechnern in diesem Studio hat, ich hatte ja mal ein, wie hieß er, von Atari ein Portfolio.
Den hab ich auch noch zu Hause liegen. Cool.
Der bewegte sich noch im Kilobyte-Bereich, oder?
Ja, das war ein 64 Kilobyte, glaub ich.
Nee, nee, 640, das war der Gipfel.
640, genau.
Da lief richtiges DOS 3 da offen und du konntest den Toro Pascal programmieren.
Richtig.
Aber eisenspaß gemacht hat das natürlich In Assembler.
Ist mir beim Zivildienst geklaut worden, das Ding.
Schweine. Schweine ist auch kaputt gegangen.
Anderen Leuten fällt das jetzt auch ins DB Klo, so während der Fahrt.
Wo ist denn an dieser Stelle, Kollegen, M-Quadrat?
Na dann lass uns einfach mal mit dem Betriebssystem...
Nee, erzähl erst mal, was du so hast.
Ich hab vom Compact den I-Pack. Neues Gerät, so seit letztem November draußen. Und ein ziemlich cooles Farbdisplay. Aber ich mag jetzt keine Werbung für Compact machen. Genau, Ingenieur?
Ja, ich hab ein Palm, also ein Gerät mit Palm OS. Und ich hab da ziemlich viel Software drauf. Wie viel MB? 4 Megabyte, aber das Wichtigste ist ja nicht die Größe, sondern die Relation. Ich meine, beim Palm sind 4 Megabyte, so wie man meint.
Das kuckt nicht auf die Größe, sondern auf die Technik.
Ah, 64 MB sind, weil...
Nein, das ist klar, weil ich hab mit meinem 4 Megabyte Palm schon immer mal Probleme gehabt, dann auch noch diesen Routenplaner drauf zu machen.
Ja.
Irgendwie echt ein bisschen schwierig.
Das hängt natürlich vom Routenplaner ab.
Das ist wahr, aber der C mit Routenplaner braucht tatsächlich 8 Megabyte beim Installieren. Echt? Sich auszupacken, jaja.
Und dann wird man eh wieder nur an den Stand von SAP geführt.
Wahrscheinlich. Aber ich stelle gerade fest, wir haben gar keinen Newton-Experten hier und der Newton ist ja eigentlich so der klassische PDA.
Das stimmt allerdings. Vielleicht hört uns ja Kollege Hofmann, also Peter Hofmann, unser Nachrichtensprecher, da ist Newton abhängig. Falls der zuhört, kann er sich ja mal melden, dann kann er mitreden.
Da man mal dazu sagen muss, dass Newton irgendwie schon tot ist.
Ja leider.
Ich hatte ja auch mal einen, aber diesen ersten, also Newton 100 hieß der, das war eine Katastrophe.
Die Teile waren eigentlich die ganze Zeit viel zu groß und viel zu schwer, aber die Technologie war cool. Heutzutage wäre das nicht größer als die Teile.
Die Technologie hat nicht funktioniert bei diesem ganzen Teil.
Die Handschrifterkennung hat bei den letzten Geräten ja perfekt funktioniert und die Keystrokes, mit denen die die Handschrift erkannt haben, die haben die einfach nicht rausgegeben. Und deswegen gibt es heute eigentlich nur noch grottige Handschriftenerkennung von Windows und will man nicht benutzen.
Klar.
Aber ich muss sagen, also mit dem Graffiti vom Palm bin ich echt zufrieden. Also der schafft das echt auch meine Handschrift zu erkennen.
Das Problem bei dem Graffiti beim Palm fand ich aber, also ich hab so nach ungefähr drei Monaten konnte ich nicht mehr schreiben. Ich hab dann immer irgendwie so ganz komische, kryptische Sachen auf Blätter geschrieben. Also wenn ich mal mit dem Stift geschrieben hab, ich mach bisweilen schreibe ich auch noch analog.
Ja, du konntest vorher auch schreiben?
Ich konnte vorher schreiben, also sogar vergleichsweise hübsch. Also ich hab so eine Mädchenschrift. Und das hat der Pam mir versaut.
Dafür kann man die Blätter auch wieder digital einlesen.
Genau.
Dafür hab ich ihm dann ja auch eine Schere ins Display gesteckt.
Aber Gerüchte besagen ja, dass der Newton ausgestorben ist, weil die Leute nicht bereit waren, Newton's Crypt zu programmieren. Die wollten halt C programmieren oder Assembler. Und eigentlich ist so eine Form, sollte man Assembler oder C programmieren. Und eigentlich ist Newton's Crypt eine tolle Sprache und dynamisch und einfach und so weiter und so fort. Aber offensichtlich haben es die Leute nicht angenommen. Heutzutage programmieren sie dann doch Visual Basic, was auf jeden Fall schlimmer ist als Newton's Crypt. Aber was soll's.
Ihr habt ja vorerst fragen können.
Einmal mit kompletter Runtime in einem Umgebung da auf dem Palmen, was man nur zwei Megabyte wegnimmt, da macht irgendwie gar nichts mehr Spaß. Und das ist langsamer. Aber die Leute wollten bunt klicken und wollen einfach programmieren, ohne sich da wirklich anzustrengen.
Die meisten wollen ja noch nicht mal programmieren.
Also eigentlich nur klicken.
Ja, sicher. Was steht denn auf dem Monitor? Chaosradio 59. Wir wollen über PDAs reden, über Personal Digital Assistance. Und worüber redet ihr so? MP3s, die hier abgespielt werden sollen?
Genau, zum Glück.
Die Szenen spielen sich hier ab.
Zum Glück sind wir genügend Leute, sodass wir drei hochbezahlte Spezialisten auf das Problem werfen können, MP3s auf diesem Laptop abzuspielen. Ich denke mal, in einer Stunde ist mit einem Ergebnis zu rechnen.
Ja, wollen wir mal reinhören? Vielleicht kommt hier schon was, oder? Da, nicht schlecht.
Ja, aber auch nur links.
Nur links und viel übersteuert, ja wie ihr. Fritz, der Sender mit der Übersteuerung.
Und dem beweglichen Teil.
Und dem beweglichen Teil. Beziehungsweise haben wir heute gar keine beweglichen Teile hier.
Eigentlich sind ja Kabel auch illent. Kabel will man nicht haben.
Dann tun wir. Also ich hätte zum Beispiel gerne das von Nokia, dieses Cardphone. Das ist auch nicht schlecht. Das kann HSDSD. Und das will ich.
Das ist super praktisch. Es gibt ja für die Alphex auch den Cradle. Und da kann man sich dieses Teil da reinstecken. Dann kann man unterwegs webklicken.
Also kurz für die Landwirtschaft, Cradle ist so ein Ding, das wird hinten an diesem PDA drangesteckt. Und da kann man dann Karten rein tun.
Genau.
Doppelkopf.
Oder auch nicht.
Typ 2 Karten. So ziemlich alles was es gibt, Waveline oder auch ein ganz normales Netz. Oder Skasi-Karten hab ich schon drin gehabt, dass du dann zum kleinen PDA auch mal eine Skasi-Platte anschließen kannst. Macht Laune.
Und dann mal gucken, wie schnell der platzt, wenn man ihn vollbildet.
Also um mal den Palm zu verteidigen. Das braucht man doch eh nicht.
Wenn du dein Mikrofon ein bisschen näher an den Mundrand tust, dann versteht man nicht mehr.
Ok, besser? Also ich mein, die Windows CE-powered Palmtops sind ja alle total überladen mit Software, mit irgendwie Grafik, Sound. Du möchtest natürlich einen Internet Explorer mit Java drauf haben, aber...
Ist ja drauf.
Ist ja drauf, genau.
Ich finde das auch ganz furchtbar. Du kannst ja auch nichts rausschmeißen.
Ja, das ist ja...
Also bei einem normalen Windows kannst du ja mal sagen, komm jetzt mal Internet Explorer und vor allen Dingen Outlook bitte weg. Aber das geht bei Windows CE nicht, ich versuch's ja schon.
Aber ich denke, man sollte auf jeden Fall unterscheiden zwischen Geräten selbst und den Betriebssystemen, die da drauf laufen. Also eigentlich sind diese IPEX sehr super coole Geräte. Da ist eine 160 MHz RISC CPU drin.
Nee, 206 MHz.
206, die haben aufgerüstet.
Aber das sind eigentlich nicht mehr PDAs im ursprünglichen Sinne, das sind irgendwie nur noch Computer, die man tragen kann, wo irgendwie durch Zufall PDAs zu verlaufen.
32 MB RAM und sowas hatte ich vor sechs Jahren als Workstation auf meinem Schreibtisch zu stehen. Genau. Und da kann man sich natürlich auch ein Unix darauf installieren, so NetBSD oder Linux oder gibt es noch andere obscure Betriebssysteme? NetBSD, ne? Das sind die beiden wichtigsten, aber da kann man sich ein Emacs drauf tun und dann kann man sich schon wie an einem richtigen Computer fühlen auf so einem PDA.
Was war das im Hintergrund gerade für ein Geräusch? Das war der iPack, ne? Nein, das war der Z50. Dann erklären wir den Leuten doch vielleicht auch noch, was das Z50 ist.
Das Z50, das ist ein Workpad von IBM. Das ist eigentlich fast ein Notebook, aber keine beweglichen Teile. Keine festfette, kein gar nichts, kein C-Dromlauchwerk, nur Prozessor, Speicher und ziemlich viele Slots draußen drin. Und natürlich ein Display 640x480.
Aber nicht PDA, oder? Hat eigentlich irgendwer mal bestimmt, ab welcher Größe das nicht mehr PDA zu nennen ist oder sowas?
Also die Definition ist wie ein Small Handheld Computing Device. Handheld, ich mein, ich kann sie in die Hand nehmen, in eine.
Ja gut, kannst du denn damit auch Small Computen dann?
Also es hat einen Ratschendenrechner.
Unter Startzubehör.
Es hat auch Kontaktverwaltung. Es hat halt auch alle Features, die so ein PDA ursprünglich hatte. Bloß du kannst halt aus jedem Computer auch ein PDA machen, wenn du die entsprechende Software draufspielst, oder irgendeine Kontakte, Termine verwalten. Dafür warst du ursprünglich da. Dann kommen wir mal zur Geschichte der PDAs.
Ja, fangen wir mal an. Was war der erste?
Also der erste war glaube ich der Portfolio 1984.
Der Portfolio war ein Tick später. Und es gab vorher diese Taschenrechner von HP. Aber ich glaube, die zählen fast gar nicht. Du meinst Basic Programmierer?
Warte, die Entwicklung eindeutig zu erkennen. Also die kamen das ja auch her. Das ist eigentlich PDAs und so eine Konvergenz aus. Taschenrechner, Armbanduhr und Terminkalender, die man alle zusammengeschmissen hat.
Zwischendurch noch CD-Player. Ja, zum Beispiel beim I-Pack hast du ja irgendwie MP3.
Ja, auch Filme kann man damit abspielen.
Das heißt, um irgendwie einen Film abzustimmen, brauch ich erstmal eine Lupe.
Da kann man eine Gameboy-Lupe drüber machen. Das wäre noch so eine Idee.
Stimmt, der Gameboy ist ja auch so eine Art PDA.
Ja, der Neue, oder? Also ich mein, dieser Gameboy Advanced.
Der hat auch die Strong Arms von einer 6 MHz-Dimme, genau derselbe, der im I-Pack drin steckt. Also die Strong Arms, die gewinnen jetzt irgendwie massiv an Land. Also die sind eigentlich überall drinne. Ist billig, ist, Riske ist schnell.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was bei mir drin ist. Ich hab so einen Jornada.
Im Jornada ist...
Das glaub ich auch ein Arm drin.
Das ist auch ein Arm drin, richtig. In der Konkurrenz war eine MIPS-CPU drin. Im Z50 ist auch so eine embedded MIPS-CPUs. Es sind CPUs, wo eigentlich der ganze Rest des Computers schon mit auf der CPU integriert sind. Das muss man sich so vorstellen, dass da einer an einem CAD-Programm sitzt. Dann geht er auf importiere Makrobibliothek, CPU, Arm oder MIPS, oder was auch immer, dann macht er click, dann ist da so ein Bauchklotz. Dann setzt er noch einen Bauchklotz RAM-Ansteuerung daneben und einen Bauchklotz Serial-Schindstelle und einen Bauchklotz PC-Card. Dann drückt er auf Render und dann wird das compiled. Dann schickt er das File an die Chipfabrik, dann kommen ganz viele Chips und fertig ist der Computer. Das ist doch praktisch. Ja, so wird das heutzutage gemacht. Deswegen gibt es sehr viele verschiedene Embedded Chips für solche Geräte, die ziemlich viel Funktionalität vereinigen, aber eigentlich nur eine Handvoll Prozessoren, die da tatsächlich als Kern drin sind. Also ein Strong Arm ist sehr beliebt. MIPS auch. Was in etwas größeren Geräten teilweise auch drin ist, ist PowerPC und Spark. Und ja, ich glaube, die x86s haben es noch nicht in die ganz kleinen Geräte geschafft, wegen dem doch eher massiven Stromverbrauch. Aber so ab dem Setterbox-Bereich werden die auch eingesetzt.
Wobei ich glaube, in den Webcams ist auch nochmal ein x86er drin. Also ein richtiger irgendwie...
In der da?
Weiß nicht, ob es in der unbedingt einer drin ist.
In der ist ein Power-PC drin.
Da ist nicht ganz ein Mac drin.
Da ist doch gar keine Maus drin.
Eben. Komisch.
Kann man gar nicht mehr packen.
Du musst dich da vorstellen und winken.
Man kann ja immer die Stromaufnahme vergleichen. So richtig schönes Experiment. Das hat also einen Grund, dass die x86er nicht benutzt werden. Auf einer Messe irgendwann hat Arm mal vorgestellt, dass sie mit der Abwärme eines Pentiums einen Strong-Arm betrieben haben und die selber Applikation auf einem anderen Computer dann nochmal...
Also mit der Abwärmeenergie.
Mit der Abwärmeenergie eines Pentiums haben sie einen Strong-Arm nochmal betrieben.
Da war ein Peltier-Element drauf und dann der Strong-Arm dran.
Man kann auf diesen Prozess auch drauf fassen, während des Betriebs, da passiert mir noch gar nichts. Mach das mal bei einem x86er irgendwie so, Pentium, turbogekühlt, Finger drauf, ist weg.
Allerdings, der Portfolio war ein x86er.
Echt, das war ein x86?
Ja, na, mit x gleich, ich glaube, 1 oder so, weil...
x gleich 0.
8086er.
Bestimmt. Aber in der Wende war dann 8088 drin. Also viel Platz hatten sie da nicht. Gut, glauben wir die einfach mal. Genau.
Ich bringe einfach mal nächstes Mal einen mit.
Dann schrauben wir ihn auf, okay. Ne, da war ein V20 drin.
Was?
War ein V20. War kein Intel CP in dem Portfolio.
Jetzt steig ich aus. Was ist ein V20?
Das ist ein ganz, ganz früher Konkurrent von Intel gewesen.
Ne, da hast du Ungerecht. Ich hab den aufgeschraubt, da stand Intel drauf.
Meine Damen und Herren, wir erleben technische Schwierigkeiten.
Wenn, dann Fritz.
22.29.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Nachts gering bewölbt oder klar bei minus 5 bis minus 9 Grad. Ach du, äh, am Tag viel Sonne bei zwei bis fünf Grad. Da wo ich herkomme, Bastian, hatten wir 14 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit eben jenem Bastian Bauner.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat am Abend einen Allantrag von Castor-Gegner im Zusammenhang mit den Demonstrationsverboten im Wendland abgelehnt. Dies teilte eine Sprecherin in Karlsruhe mit. Zwei Bürgerinitiativen hatten beantragt, auch innerhalb eines Korridors von 50 Metern links und rechts der Transportstrecke demonstrieren zu dürfen. Der erste Castor-Transport seit vier Jahren wird in Kürze an der französisch-deutschen Grenze erwartet. Im Westjordanland ist ein zehn Monate altes israelisches Baby erschossen worden. Nach Angaben des israelischen Rundfunks hatte ein palästinensischer Heckenschütze in Hebron auf den Vater gefeuert, der das Kind in seinen Armen hielt. In Hebron leben einige hundert jüdische Siedler unter mehr als 100.000 Arabern. In Ostdeutschland ist die Aktionswoche der niedergelassenen Ärzte angelaufen. Tausende Facharztpraxen blieben geschlossen. Die Mediziner verlangen für dieses Jahr 600 Millionen Mark mehr Honorar für die ambulante Versorgung ihrer Patienten. Sie verweisen darauf, dass sie bisher nur 77 Prozent des Westniveaus bekommen. Ein US-Militärflugzeug ist heute 15 Kilometer östlich von Nürnberg abgestürzt. Die Maschine fiel in ein Waldgelände. Beide Insassen des Propellermaschinen kamen ums Leben. Der Verkehr Schwedt auf der B2 wird gebaut. Ihr müsst mit erheblichen Behinderungen rechnen, wenn möglich einfach den Bereich zwischen Kreisverkehr und der Einfahrt zum Gewerbegebiet meiden.
Herzlichen Dank, Bastian, eine Minute und halb elf.
Am besten mit Freunden.
Gerne auch für 6000 Mark.
Und am allerliebsten in eine total tolle Villa irgendwo auf der Welt.
Am Samstag ab 14 Uhr in der weiten, wilden Welt. Denn dort verschenken Fritz und TD1 eine Reise.
Für 6000 Mark.
Denn am Samstag ist die weite, wilde Welt ab 14 Uhr zu Gast in der Villa.
Im legendären Live-Telefon-Chat.
Und wer dabei ist, kann eins von vielen TD1-Xtrapex gewinnen.
Oder die Reise von Tui.
Für 6000 Mark.
In die Villa.
Und übrigens, wer jetzt schon mal in die Villa will, testet www.divilla.de.
Oder wählt mit seinem TD1-Handy die 4 88 88.
Gewonnen wird am Samstag ab 14 Uhr.
In der weiten wilden Welt.
Fangen das Licht, fangen das Licht, Chaosradio 59. Schönen guten Abend hier auf Fritz. Jetzt hat der Wetterfrosch den Weg ans Mikrofon gefunden. Hallo.
Hallo.
Was wolltest du denn mitreden? Also wir wollten ja über PDAs sprechen.
Genau, das war das eigentliche Thema in der Sendung und ich hab ein bisschen was zu Palm hauptsächlich zu sagen und ich wollte auch noch ein bisschen Grundlagen machen.
Zu Palm zu sagen? Also die Kollegen fragen immer, ich will mir jetzt mal einen Palm kaufen, soll ich das machen?
Es ist im Grunde keine falsche Entscheidung und es gibt halt noch andere Hersteller, die PDAs ausgeben mit Palm OS, das eine wäre zum Beispiel Handspring.
Handspring, TAG Pro beziehungsweise Handira, die haben sich gerade umbenannt. Samsung macht bald ein Smartphone mit Palm OS, das sieht auch echt sexy aus. Kann man sich anschauen unter palmstation.com, da gibt es glaube ich einen Link drauf. Es gibt Kyocera, das ist ein amerikanisches Unternehmen, die hat auch irgendwie Palmphones schon seit mehreren Jahren oder Generationen. Es gibt schon mehrere Kyocera Modelle und es gibt auch geteilte Meinungen dazu. Also manche sind ganz begeistert und manche finden das ganz toll.
Ok, 900 MHz Handys aus.
Na, wo war das?
Das war nicht aus.
Ne, das war nicht aus, das üben wir nochmal. Ja genau, Akku ab ist immer eine gute Lösung. Ok. Erzähl doch mal was zum Palm.
Zum Palm, was gibt es zum Palm zu sagen? Also die Palm-Serie hat eigentlich angefangen mit den Palm Professional, das war der allererste Palm.
Palm Personal, wenn ich mich nicht an der Seite ändere.
Personal, dann der Professional. Dann folgte die Dreier-Serie. Dabei gab es, die Dreier-Serie besaß 2 MB RAM und standardmäßig das Palm OS 2.7.
Ich kann das gerne noch mal nachschlagen, wenn ich das so genau interessiert.
Parallel dazu hat IBM baugleiche Geräte von Palm gekauft und hat IBM drauf gelabelt und die dann für den Hunderter weniger verschärbelt. Hieß WorkPad zurzeit.
Ja, wobei das natürlich auch echt nur für Firmenkunden eigentlich original gedacht war. So hier, also der Palm 1000 war der erste und hatte 128 Kilobyte RAM. Wobei man dazu sagen muss, dass Palm irgendwie nur eine Art Speicher hat. Also er hat nicht irgendwie Festplatte und RAM, so wie man es von normalen Computern her kennt, sondern er hat einmal einen ROM, wo das Betriebssystem drin ist und dann hat er nochmal RAM, wo alle Daten, alle Programme, alles drauf ist. Und es gibt also auch nicht irgendwie Dateien oder Nicht-Dateien und vielleicht noch Streams oder so, sondern man hat immer irgendwie Datenbanken und das passt halt alles drauf.
Zu dem RAM erst zu sagen, man kann sich alte RAM-Scheine nehmen, sie ein bisschen umlöten, neue Chips draufstecken, Anleitungen dazu lassen sich im Netz finden, einbauen und dann hat man halt nochmal 8MB anstatt 2MB und das geht bei den Palm 3er eigentlich ziemlich gut. Ich hab's selber noch nicht ausprobiert. Und es verbraucht jetzt wesentlich viel Akku-Zeit, das heißt, da musste man dann sparsam sein.
Aber nochmal wieder zur Palm-Geschichte. Nach dem Palm 1000 kam der Palm 5000 mit 512 KB, danach der Palm Pilot Personal, von dem du gesprochen hast, der hatte zum ersten Mal ein Backlit, also eine Beleuchtung, und einen erhöhten Kontrast in seiner Anzeige, das heißt also nicht irgendwie nur grau und irgendwie ganz dunkel, sondern man konnte zum ersten Mal auch mal was lesen drauf.
Aber Janine, lass uns das mal erzählen, warum man den Leuten empfehlen sollte, einen Palm irgendwie sich zu besorgen, weil so online die Geschichte vorlesen ist nicht so spannend. Also wenn irgendjemand fragt, das geile am Palm ist doch, dass er irgendwie leicht ist, dass er klein ist, dass er überall hinpasst und dass er auch für ein paar hundert Bucks irgendwie zu holen ist.
Also dass er Webseiten nicht richtig renden darf.
Entschuldigung.
Doch, das macht der mal. Du hattest auch nicht Palmscape.
Was hatte ich denn? Diodora Internet.
Proxyweb ist auch ganz interessant.
Proxyweb ist ganz spaßig, stimmt. Aber ich hab dann als erstes, weil ich mir dachte, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß, den Proxy-Server auskommentiert. Und mich gewundert, warum die Scheiße nicht funktioniert.
Ja, also das ist zu erstaunt zu sagen, Proxyweb arbeitet mit einem Proxy, der steht irgendwo im weiten Internet.
Kann man ja aus dem Namen heraus schließen.
Und wenn man jetzt auf chaosradio.ccc.de gehen will, wird dieser Request an den Proxy geleitet. Der holt sich die Seite und bereitet sich speziell für Palmen auf. Das heißt, er schiebt die Image ein bisschen kleiner, macht daraus weniger Farben und das Ganze eigentlich Palmen aufbereitet, dass dann halt im Endeffekt weniger Speicher für die Einzelheiten im Meld-Dateien anfallen. Ja, und Proxy-Mail gibt es auch. Das wäre dann das gleiche nur für Mail.
Wobei Proxyweb gibt es als Produkt so weit gar nicht mehr. Das wurde von IntelliSync aufgekauft. Und gibt es jetzt also unter irgendwie intellisync.com oder so etwas. Ja, genau. Zu deiner Frage, warum man sich einen Palm holen sollte. Also Palm hat, so einfach ist das nicht. Also der Palm ist nicht einfach nur klein und leicht und kostet wenig, sondern irgendwie der Palm hat einfach die Funktion, die man braucht. Die Leute haben sich hingesetzt und haben gedacht, hey, lass uns mal einen Handheld bauen, den wir selber haben wollen. Und sie haben sich überlegt, was braucht man denn für Applikationen? Man möchte irgendwie seine Adressen immer dabei haben. Man möchte was kurz aufschreiben können. Man möchte halt den Tagesplan mit haben und das reicht eigentlich auch.
Eine Uhr will man bestimmt auch dabei haben.
Ja, das natürlich auch, aber das kriegt halt irgendwie also eine Standard-Uhr gab es zu der Zeit irgendwie auch schon. Ja, und man möchte natürlich auf jeden Fall erweiterungsfähig sein und man möchte auch Kommunikation haben. Deswegen haben sie das Ding halt gebaut und bzw. sie wollten eigentlich erst mal von Fremdfirmen bauen lassen. Das ging dann nicht und haben dann sich einfach kurz entschlossen, einen Design auszudenken und haben das halt selber gebaut. Und die ersten Palms gingen halt nicht so schnell von der Hand, aber sie haben sich halt nicht beirren lassen und haben dann immer weitergemacht. Also das Ideal an Palm ist, dass er für sein Gewicht sehr, sehr viel Leistung bietet. Du hast auf sehr, sehr wenig Platz die Möglichkeit, sehr, sehr große oder auch irgendwie sinnvolle Programme zu haben. Und er hat halt alle Features, die man braucht. Also ich hab bisher irgendwie mal in Palm war ich so weit glücklich, ich konnte irgendwie nicht mir eine Anwendung ausdenken, wo ich sagen müsste, ja der Palm kann das jetzt nicht machen.
Naja und man muss dazu auch noch sagen, der Palm war eins der ersten End-User PDAs, wo auch wirklich SDKs, Software Development Kids verfügbar waren. Das heißt, da wurde freiverfügbar. Da haben sich dann auch gleich ein paar tausend Leute daran gesessen und geschrieben. Mittlerweile gibt es da irgendwie 120.000 Programme.
Ja, das ist wirklich geil. Gibt sogar einen ERC-Klein.
Ja, ein SSH-Klein.
Es gibt einen PGP-Software für den ICQ.
Irgen mit einem Palm ist irgendwie schon total arm. Also wenn du da sitzt und deine komischen Symbole eingibst.
Hast du etwa nicht den Keyboard, den man da drunter klappt? Dann kann man dem Zug super irgendwie alles immer.
Ich hab eine Schere im Display stecken. Da kaufe ich mir nicht so ein Keyboard.
Naja, also wie gesagt, das Einzige, was er nicht kann, ist MP3-Planen. Er kann Wave-Data ausgeben und er kann Videos anzeigen, aber er kann nicht MP3.
Zumal das mit den neuen Geräten auch gelöst werden soll, da gibt es dann Ansteckmodule, die steckt man in eine sehr regelreiche Schnittstelle. Und von Handstring, die stellen ihre Visuas aus mit einem PCMC-A-Slot, also es hat diese Belegung. Andere Module kommen da rein, da gibt es dann, wir schätzen da, dass da auch ein paar tausend Module geben wird, größtenteils Software, zum Beispiel Spiele, oder halt auch sowas wie Digitalkamera, MP3-Player, Mini-Disc, eventuell und solche Geschichten.
Ja, da sollte man...
Sollte ich mir nicht eh lieber einen Visor holen? Das ist ja nicht... Also ich mein, da ist hinten ein Schaf drin und der ist billiger.
Billiger und hat noch dieses schöne Feature.
Hat aber einen Nachteil, und zwar die Handspring-Visors können ihr OS nicht updaten. Du kaufst ein Gerät mit einem Betriebssystem und kannst das Betriebssystem nicht nachher aktueller machen. Das hat bis vor kurzem echt Spaß gemacht, weil jede OS-Version konntest du einfach direkt auf deinen Palm spielen. Du konntest mit einem Personal bis vor kurzem alle aktuellen Applikationen fahren, auch wenn die vom Speicher nicht immer draufgepasst haben. Und seit der 3.5er Version hat Palm sich überlegt, hey, das wäre viel cooler, wenn wir für die Betriebssysteme Geld haben wollen, so wie Microsoft. Und das machen sie jetzt, also kostet das irgendwie 15 Mark oder 15 Dollar, genau. Und dann musst du dir noch Shipping-Cost mit UPS zahlen, das ist dann nochmal 300 Prozent davon. Und dann kriegst du irgendwie so eine beschissene CD, mit der du dann dein Betriebssystem unter Umständen abkriegen kannst.
Zumal man da eine eingeschränkte Version von diesem OS auch von palm.com runterladen kann. Ja, eingeschränkt. Es gibt irgendwie so ein paar Features, nicht was eigentlich ziemlich stressig ist, aber wer da mal reinschauen will, da ist 352. In den nächsten Wochen erscheint das Palm 4, in den nächsten Wochen, Monaten ist damit zu rechnen, dass Palm es releaset und ja.
Ja, wobei das auch nicht so viele aktuelle Features enthält. Also die haben das halt nur die Bugs entfernt.
Und sie setzen noch mehr Internet.
Ja, das geht auch.
16 MB RAM oder 8 MB?
Das Problem war beim Palm, also es gibt ja den 68000er Prozessor, der wurde in den alten Macs vor dem PowerPC benutzt und deswegen haben die Leute sich damit natürlich auch sehr, sehr viel beschäftigt und haben da auch Linux draufgefahren. Und als die gemerkt haben, auf dem Palm ist ein 88000er drauf, wollten sie ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert. Und die haben es echt geschafft. Also der Punkt war, beim Palm fehlt ein bestimmter Chip und dieser Chip macht die Memory, wie war das? Also Swapping, er macht halt...
Die MMU hat gefehlt.
Genau, die MMU hat gefehlt. Und das haben sie sich von einem Customs Memory-Chip-Hersteller nachbauen lassen auf eine Speicherkarte. Haben die eingebaut und haben dann wirklich ein Linux drauf gebootet. Das Linux hat gebootet und hat einen User-Prozess gefahren und dieser User-Prozess sagte irgendwie Hallo auf dem Bildschirm.
Immerhin, Mensch. Die Musik ist aus, wir sind immer noch da. Chaosradio 59, wir reden über PDAs Personal Digital Assistance und da hat schon einer angerufen. Hallo Sven.
Und zwar, ich wollte mal fragen, ich hab eure Diskussion zum Halbmitglied gekriegt oder eure Unterhaltung jetzt wegen Palm und zwar bei der ECBED sind da eine ganze Menge Sachen vorgestellt worden, Peripherieräte, die mich nicht ganz interessieren, aber ein Bekannter von mir, der hat mal einen Xeon jetzt sich besorgt und von der Anwendung, von den ganzen Drumherum, was da jetzt möglich ist, fand ich da so auch kein Tristan. Vielleicht könnt ihr da mal ein paar Sachen dazu sagen als Vergleich, so Xeon und Palm.
Ja, na der Xeon Organizer ist mehr so die, würde ich sagen, Variante für das Business oder so.
Also es hat einen Touchscreen zum Cappuccino Working.
Es hat einen Touchscreen und eine Tastatur, mit der man fast mit 10 Fingern tippen kann. Ist ein bisschen schwammig, aber okay, 8 Fingern, okay, gut.
Zumal die das in den Xeon Serie 5 wesentlich verbessert haben. Das heißt, man hat jetzt auch Tasten mit Anschlag und allem. Habe ich mir gestern vorgestern auf AC-Bit an geschaut.
Ja, man hat Tasten mit Anschlag, aber es ist nicht so den Anschlag, den man eigentlich hat.
Das ist kein IBM Keyboard.
Genau.
Kann man nicht ein IBM Keyboard anschließen?
An diesem Psyon kann man kein Keyboard anschließen.
Dann wäre es ja auch kein PDA mehr.
Es hat nur einen seriellen Anschluss, aber es ist 232 und da kann man dann Kommunikation mit einem PC oder sonst was machen. Infrarot hat es eben auch noch und macht dann IRDA, Standard, ganz normal.
Das macht Palm doch auch?
Ja, ich sage nur, dass es so Outputs hat.
Also ich glaube, der größte Vorteil von einem Psyon gegenüber einem Palm ist sein riesiges Display. Also es ist genau doppelt so groß wie das von Palm. Es hat halt eine Tastatur. Wenn du viele Texte schreiben willst, wenn du viel arbeiten willst, wenn du ein Luxus-PDA haben willst, ist Psyon eigentlich dein Ding, weil du hast da auch Software. Der Nachteil für den Privat-User ist in dem Moment, weil Psyon eben ein Luxus-PDA ist, musst du für die meiste Software blechen. Das ist beim Palm nicht der Fall. Beim Palm hast du fast alles in Freeware.
Das stimmt nicht ganz. Es gibt Gameboy-Emulatoren als Freeware. Es gibt einen Linux da drauf.
Auf dem Psyon?
Es gibt dort einen Linux.
Zeig mal.
Nein, kann ich nicht vorführen. Habe ich die Flash nicht bei.
Es gibt einen Linux, ich zeig's dir. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Was sollte dich dazu bewegen, einen Psyon zu kaufen? Also wenn du Spaß daran hast, wenn du Windows Intuitiv findest, dann wirst du mit einem Psyon lieben.
Und ein weiterer Nachteil ist, der eigentlich ziemlich hoher Preis im Verhältnis zum Palm. Also der Finware kostet jetzt 1, 4. Kommt hin. Und dann hat Psyon noch das Webpad rausgebracht, also da hat man dann wirklich eine Tastatur wie beim Z50, ein großes Display und der kostet dann allerdings 2000 Mark. 3000 Mark.
Lohnt sich ja kaum fast, würde ich sagen.
Und dann tut man so ein Z50 bei eBay hier ab 500 Mark.
Oder wie Andreas vorhin erwähnt hat, ein Sony Vaio Laptop mit PC drin und Standard.
Wobei du möchtest kein PC haben. Also irgendwie. Das bootet doch.
Intel.
Das ist im Prinzip so ein Lüschding jetzt zwischen Palm und PC.
Genau. Ja, was auch ein großes Problem von Xeon war, dass die das Marketing immer falsch gemacht haben. Die konnten also ihre Geräte zwar bauen, aber nicht wirklich verkaufen. In der größten Markt in den USA sind sie halt ganz gefloppt. Und weil das halt Europäer sind, war denen wahrscheinlich das auch aus Stolz nicht so wichtig. Und dadurch sind die Preise halt auch heute noch immer sehr, sehr hoch. Bei Palm sind die Preise halt deutlich runtergegangen.
Ja, ich kenne mich zion jetzt eigentlich ein bisschen überrascht von meiner Arbeit, so Programmiergeräte für Steuerung und so. Und insofern war ich ein bisschen überrascht darin, so was zu sehen. Und dann habe ich dann mit der Zeit mitgekriegt, wie vielfältig die eigentlich doch ihre Geräte jetzt haben. Also dass das nicht nur so auf irgendwie diesen Privatbereich jetzt beschränkt ist, sondern irgendwo scheinbar in der Industrie ein bisschen mehr Anwendung findet.
Ja, also beim Palm gibt es da irgendwie Lizenznehmer, die bauen da Barcodescanner ein. Da kannst du durch das Lager gehen und dann irgendwie direkt auf den Palm, die Datenbank führen und dann einfach per Tastendruck mit dem Firmennetzwerk abgleichen. Du kannst also direkt ins Netzwerk sinken und dann hast du einfach also deutlich weniger Arbeit.
Es gibt auch Programme für die Rindviehhaltung, wo man da merken kann, wie viele Kühe gerade gewohnt werden, wann welche gemastert werden.
Ja, das erübrigt sich ja so langsam.
Vielleicht muss ich ihm jetzt auch pleite.
Das muss man jetzt updaten auf Hühnchen.
Genau. Sven, alle Unklarheiten beseitigt?
Wir sind zum Schluss mal den Preis vergleichen. Also ihr sagt ja, es ist so ein bisschen höherwertig, vom Cion die ganzen Gerätschaften, die jetzt so neu angeboten werden. Soweit eigentlich vom Cion von der Cion nichts gehört. Gibt es da jetzt auch so eine Sache mit Modemanbindung und Webcam und sowas alles wie beim Palm? Oder ist das dann nicht so gewesen?
Es gibt nicht gerade so viele Add-ons, auch seit diese Flashkarten. Da hat Palm zum Beispiel die Palm Picks. Und du hast gerade eben nochmal zum Preis gefragt. Palm kann man nicht wirklich gut vergleichen. Palm fängt bei Fynat Mark an, kleinste Version, hat auch keine Tastatur, halt nur Stifteingabe. Und geht rüber 800, 1000 aufwärts. Und Cion fängt halt bei 1400 erst an, oder? Genau, bis 3000 und eigentlich oben offen.
Also die Erweiterungsmöglichkeiten von Cion, du hast halt Combat Flash Karten, und da gibt es halt auch Modems und GPS-Geräte und Ethernet und so was alles. Also die Frage ist dann natürlich, ob die Treiber dafür auch irgendwie auf dem Cion laufen. Das musst du dann jeweils irgendwie rausfinden. Also du musst erstmal wissen, wofür du das Ding benutzen willst und dann kannst du sagen, was du dir eigentlich kaufst. Das ist eigentlich bei allen Technik-Gerätschaften der richtige Weg.
Und jetzt ist die Bitszeit, kann man nochmal sagen, falls jemand da sein wird, Halle 13, da gibt es diese ganzen Palm Handhelds Endconsumer-Devices. Genau.
Und machs gut Sven, danke für deinen Anruf. Stifteingabe fällt mir gerade so ein. Wie geht das bei diesem I-Pack von Compact? Wie gebe ich da meinen Krempel ein? Also da muss dann Erdgeist wieder kommen.
Ja, Halle Erdgeist.
Zwei Möglichkeiten, da kann man sich das aussuchen per Default. Da gibt es rechts unten so einen Button und da kann man sich schon aussuchen, ob man Schrifterkennung oder eine Tastatur aufbaut.
Das ist die echte Handschrifterkennung. Also nicht, wo du auch so eine Kurzschrift lernen musst, wie beim Palm, diese Graffiti, sondern...
Diese Kurzschrift ist halt auch der normalen Algebra Zeichen. Sehr ähnlich, das heißt, ein A, da fehlt halt der Querstrich, aber...
Ist klar, beim Palm weiß ich, aber wie sieht es beim IPAC aus? Relativ ähnlich.
Ähnlich, aber schon verbessert. Sie haben da mal ein bisschen Manpower drauf geworfen und noch ein bisschen mehr Keystrokes sich einfallen lassen, dass irgendwie auch alle Buchstaben erkennen, aber es ist irgendwie noch nicht perfekt, also ich benutze es gar nicht. Ich benutze mal die Tastatur. Das war ein ziemliches Getippe, aber man gewöhnt sich dran. Und ich hab es auch schon geschafft, damit über die Webseite zu chatten.
Also eine eingeblendete Tastatur, wo du mit dem Stift drauf rumfließt.
Und die wird bei Bedarf, wenn man also in einem schreibbaren Icon drin ist, wird die aufgeklappt und wenn man wieder rausgeht wird die wieder zugeklappt, sodass die restliche Bildschirm noch zur Verfügung steht.
Aber der weiß halt, letzter Schluss ist das nicht, ne?
Nee, also Interface ist ja bei so PDAs sowieso ein Problem. Was ist ja, einerseits hast du die Entwicklung zu immer kleineren Geräten, aber andererseits kannst du die gar nicht mehr benutzen, weil du halt nichts mehr reinkriegst, und dazu müsstest du dann irgendwie mal eine vernünftige Spracherkennung geben. Aber so, irgendwie jeder Informatik-Student im ersten Semester weiß, dass eine perfekte Spracherkennung irgendwie KI dahinter braucht. Kriegt man so ohne Weiteres auf einem PDA nicht drauf. Und, ja, das andere wäre auch noch eine bessere Schrifterkennung.
Auf der anderen Seite möchtest du eigentlich weder wirklich Spracherkennung, noch wirklich eine Schrifterkennung haben, weil beides, also Schrift und Sprache, ist ja eigentlich viel zu langsam. Wenn du eine E-Mail schreibst, bist du mit einem Zehnfingersystem sicher. Was du wirklich haben willst, ist eine anschließbare Tastatur. Das gibt es bei Palm zum Beispiel. Da hast du so eine samfaltbare Tastatur, die du anschließen kannst. Du hast auf dem Xeon dieses ausklappbare Tastatur. Bei den C-Geräten, zumindest bei den größeren, wie dem Z51 oder Z50, wie das heißt, hat die Tastatur wie bei einem Laptop drin.
Und zu schreiben, die PDAs sind dazu, dass man sich zum Beispiel in Zug setzt, halt mobil ist und immer schön seine E-Mail schreiben kann. Wenn man jetzt gerade kein Netz hat, speichern. Zehn Minuten später, wenn man Netz hat, mal E-Mails schicken. Oder dafür haben halt alle Geräte auch eine sogenannte Hot-Sync-Funktion, so wird das bei Pam genannt. Man schießt die Geräte via USB-Infrarot oder Sellerie an den Rechner und dann drückt man auf den Knopf und dann werden die Daten abgeglichen. Und da können halt auch Fotos mit übertragen werden oder aufgenommene Videos.
Das entscheidende ist aber, dass die E-Mails von dem Super ein. Da gibt es immer noch die Eingabe von Schriften, mit denen du mit dem Computer sprichst, also Schrift oder Zeichen. Und da gibt es dann demnächst Bluetooth-Lösungen, dass eine Tastatur einfach mal daneben dazu gehört oder nicht. Und zur Zeit habe ich schon gesehen, dass ein guter Freund, Ecke, ich laufe mal gegrüßt, der hat sich... Der hat eigentlich, glaube ich, eine alte Ericssen-Kleider-Tastatur zu sich gerettet. Genau, und hat das irgendwie unten an den iPad angesteckt und hat dann irgendwie so mit einer kleinen Schnur und einer kleinen Tastatur noch mit dabei, die er dann irgendwie bei Bedarf rausgeholt hat.
Das ist doch eigentlich das, was man haben möchte.
Das ist was man haben möchte. Gibt es aber nicht zu kaufen.
Es war. Wir hören uns zwar aus Chaosradio 59. Eigentlich wollten wir über PDAs reden, aber wir finden die Musik so gut. Und darum hören wir uns die ganze Zeit an.
Hier haben wir noch ein paar Chaosradio News.
Ach, ja, Chaos. Im Rahmen des 1000-Job-Programmes sucht das Bundeskriminalamt einen Meister für die Technische Überwachungszentrale. Anforderungen und Schichtdienst-Tauglichkeit und die Möglichkeit, das Gewissen zu Hause zu lassen, sind möglich. Nähere Informationen unter www.bka.de. Ne, echt?
Natürlich.
www.bka.de, Jobangebote und dann hast du da Sohn, die einen Meister für Überwachungstechnologie.
Hier haben wir noch einen Sucheabruf. Die Polizei bitte um Mithilfe. Seit dem 30. Januar werden zwei Klasse-3-Zertifikate auf dem Namen Microsoft Corporation vermisst. Zuletzt wurden sie bei einem angeblichen Mitarbeiter von Microsoft gesehen. Sollten sich diese Zertifikate durch Zufall in ihrem Besitz befinden, zertifizieren sie bitte umgehend sämtliche Viren, die sie auf ihrer Festplatte befinden und stellen sie diese auf den einschlägigen WS-Seiten der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung.
Jo, Mitte Juli vom 13. bis 15. Juli 2001, um genau zu sein, findet die DEFCON in Las Vegas statt. http://devcon.org Schiff 7. Wenn man hier von Deutschland dorthin befliegen möchte, kostet der hin und zurückflugt um die 1500 Mark.
Ja, nette Veranstaltung.
Genau, hier noch eine aktuelle Verkehrsmeldung. Na, viele...
Amerikanische Hacker treffen sich und trinken ganz viel Bier.
Okay, jetzt die Verkehrsmeldung. Morgen ist in der Zeit von 16 Uhr bis in die späten Abendstunden mit sehr fließendem Publikumsverkehr vor dem Cebit-Stadt der Firma Siemens zu rechnen. Grund sind hier willkürliche Filtermaßnahmen.
Mein Kollege Steffen Halaschka moderiert da übrigens bei Siemens.
Na ja, es gibt da noch eine URL dazu.
http.doppelslashköln.ccc.de slash Projekte mit K slash ccc ebit slash.
Ccc ebit.
Genau, das waren die Chaosradio News.
Rainer Ralf, Chaosradio 59, wir reden über PDAs.
Was ist das denn?
Taschenrecher mit Modem drin?
Genau. Ich hab ja derzeit keinen PDA, ich hatte mal einen Palm und der ist mir dann irgendwann kaputt gegangen und ich hab beschlossen eigentlich keinen mehr zu kaufen, bis es ein Gerät gibt, was sowohl ein Mobiltelefon als auch PDA in einem ist. Und bitte schön mit Internet, 24 Stunden am Tag und Volumenabrechnungen, nicht nach Zeit.
Dann nimmst du einfach den neuen Nokia-Communicator mit GPRS. Da hast du deine Volumen abgeschlossen. Also ich hab vor gut sechs Wochen mir Telekom angeguckt, also TD1 GPRS und das billigstmögliche waren 19 Pfennige pro angefangene 10k. Ja und das teuerste, also das ist der Business-Tarif. Dann gibt es doch irgendwie den Privat-Tarif, da kostet es dann 69 Pfennige pro angefangene 10kb. Das heißt, wenn du...
Einmal heise angucken kostet?
Einmal heise angucken, nee, also ich weiß nicht mehr, einmal Fritz-Homepage angucken, also www.fritz.de slash index hat exakt 100k und das kostet also im ungünstigsten Fall 7 Mark. Aber, du wolltest doch Volumen abbrechen.
Ja, na vielleicht irgendwie zu realistischen Preisen.
Mit einem realistischen Tempo?
Ja, na also 9, 6 reichen mir völlig.
Nee, PAS macht doch 28, 8, sagen die. Das Baby hat ein 28, 8er Modem. Du bist zero cool.
Ja, aber was uns interessiert ist, ob ihr Handheld-Geräte bei euch führt und wenn ja, was für welche und wenn nein, warum noch nicht und ob ihr damit glücklich seid. Und du darfst jetzt auf den Knopf drücken.
Ich darf jetzt auf den Knopf drücken. Mit ihr wart übrigens ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, gemein.
Genau. So, jetzt mal anrufen hier. 0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Denn das ist eine Sendung zum Mitreden. Wir wollen wissen, ob ihr tragbare Geräte tragt oder nicht und wenn nicht, warum nicht und wenn ja, warum ihr euch dafür entschieden habt, das zu kaufen.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Failure to comply with force, the industry to escalate the incident to an illegal operation. Occasional extreme cases may require fatal exception.
Music by Taloneel, Zitate von Jengia. Du kannst jetzt den Kopfhörer auch aufsetzen, du hast das gerade im Radio gesagt. Sag jetzt auch mal was das war.
Das kommt aus der Datenschleune.
Genau, das steht auf der zweiten Seite und ist betitelt mit Human Error. Resistance is futile, the industry.
Das ist doch klar. Hier ist Chaosradio 59 und wir wollen über PDAs reden, und zwar mit euch, zum Beispiel mit dir, Micha. Hallöchen.
Ich hätte erstmal eine einfache Frage. Ich habe einen CE in Aero, 2120, und der ist ja updatefähig auf dem Pocket PC. Leider nur für Englisch. Compact selber war mir nicht in der Lage, da ich ein deutsches Gerät körpern muss, warum habe ich zu sagen, ob das auch mit deutschen Geräten funktioniert.
Du hast eine echt spezifische Frage, muss ich dazu sagen. Ja. Können wir dazu beantworten? Also der User möchte gerne wissen, ob er...
Dann gib ihm doch einfach den Kopfhörer. Wir üben hier noch mich, aber wir kriegen das hin. Okay, darf ich die Frage bitte noch hören?
Noch mal stellen?
Ja, mach das nochmal bitte.
Alles klar. Und zwar, ich habe einen Compaq Aero 2120, ist ja noch ein CE und den gibt es für die englische Version, gibt es ein Update, ist eine Backplatine mit einem anderen BOM drauf, dass der Pocket PC fähig ist, weil er eigentlich ist ja die gleiche Prozessorart wie der Hi-Tech, nur ein anderes Design. Und für die deutsche Version konnte mir Compaq nicht sagen, ob es da auch ein Update gibt.
Okay, das kann ich dir genau auch nicht sagen.
Aber wenn du die Platine austauschst, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß, dass es funktioniert, dann hast du halt hinterher ein englisches Gerät, aber das wäre der einzige Nachteil.
Das stört mich überhaupt nicht. Nee, es hätte mich ein bisschen interessiert, ob das nicht vielleicht ein 2-ROMs ist, dass es nachher wieder Probleme gibt.
Ich kann dir empfehlen, ich hole dir einen iPack, da hast du Flashs drauf, die kannst du irgendwie überspielen, wie du möchtest. Ich hab irgendwie auch schon einen Linux drauf gehabt. Macht Spaß, es hat aber irgendwie nicht mehr diese PDA-Features. Sondern es ist halt irgendwie ein Linux mit einem X drauf, und du kannst einen Web-Server mitspielen. Und einen FTP-Server oder einen Name-Server.
Mal eben einen iPack kaufen, kostet aber auch mal eben Geld.
Ach, 1300 Mark, ich glaub, das geht noch.
Das sagen wir aus der Portokasse.
Ach, das geht eigentlich. Aber genau darum ging es mir eigentlich, weil ich halt mit dem Telefon spielen wollte und wollte mir halt keinen kaufen, aber ich bin halt gebraucht zu so ein paar Geräten gekommen. Und ähm, bezüglich Schrifterkennung, was ich vorhin hatte. Es gibt ein wunderschönes Tool, das lief auf Windows CE, nannte sich Crypted, gibt es für 13 Sprachen, erkennt wunderbar Handschriften, selbst die übelsten Clown.
Crypted? Also nicht.
Ähm, nicht, aber meiner Meinung nach war das damals beim Philips Nino standardgemäß ausgeliefert worden, wenn ich nicht irre.
Das wär natürlich nochmal toll, aber müssen wir dann mal im Internet nachsuchen. Auch die Benutzer.
Ähm, gab's auch in Deutsch, also in Deutsch und Englisch hab ich sie gesehen, da lief es sehr gut.
Hast du irgendwann mal einen Newton gehabt? Kannst du das vergleichen mit der Schrifterkennung?
Besser als der Newton.
Besser als der Newton noch?
Ich hab selber einen Newton 100 und einen 130. Und den fand ich schade, dass ihr den vergessen habt eigentlich in der PDA-Geschichte, weil eigentlich hat der Apple damit angefangen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Den Newton hatten wir zwischendurch mal erwähnt, aber dann wieder unter den Tisch fallen lassen, weil wir hier keinen Newton-Experten da hatten.
Unser Newton-Experte muss aufs Kind aufpassen. Schöne Grüße an Ecke noch mal.
Kannst du mal erzählen, wie waren das so mit dem Newton? Die waren ja immer ziemlich groß und schwer, oder?
Ja, also das Optimum fände ich eigentlich für einen PDA wäre eigentlich die Größe vom Aero 1500. Der ist ein bisschen flach.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Windows-CE-Gerät. Hat die gleiche Größe wie die alten CE-Kisten. Also ist auch Farbdisplay. Nur ein bisschen flacher halt. Und müsste dann eigentlich von der Schrifterkennung her so wie der Newton und ein bisschen schneller sein. Das wäre super. Und die Knöpfe könnte man sich eigentlich völlig sparen an den Geräten.
Tja, dann schreib an Apple. Die haben das irgendwie eingestellt, weil sie sich ja vollständig auf Mac OS für ihre Power-PCs eingeschossen haben.
Na, Apple hatte damals echt schwere Probleme. Die mussten die Hälfte ihrer Forschungsabteilung zu machen. Und da ist unter anderem der Newton unter den Tisch gefallen und entfingen ein paar fortgeschrittene Sprach-Forschungseinrichtungen, die Apple Dillon betrieben haben, was eine Programmiersprache war, die mal für den Newton gedacht war und so weiter und so fort. Es ist eigentlich ein bisschen schade, war fortgeschrittene Technologie auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich fand ihn auch von der Bedienung ja eigentlich sehr angenehm, obwohl ich ansonsten nicht von Apple-Fan bin, zugegebener Maßen. Weil ich berufsmäßig halt viel mit Intel zu tun habe, mit Intel-basierenden Geräten. Aber das wollte ich halt eigentlich nur mal erwähnen und die Frage halt, ob ihr da schon mal Erfahrung gehabt hattet nach dem Update von CE nach Pogspitze.
Alles klar.
Einen schönen Abend noch. Danke für deinen Anruf.
Es gibt noch mal eine kleine Ansage zu machen. Wir sind auch jetzt im Chat unter irg.ccc.de im Channel Chaosradio. Und falls ihr jetzt gerade aus dem Ländegebiet fahrt und Internet habt auf eurem PDA.
Oder im neuen Porsche.
Dann könnt ihr unter chaosradio.ccc.de herausfinden, wie ihr diese Sendung auch über mp3-Stream hören könnt.
Herzlichen Dank für diesen Hinweis. Schönen guten Abend, Roman.
Ja, ich hab seit einem Monat einen ganz super kleinen, super praktischen PDA. Und zwar Siemens C35i Handy. Ich finde, der erfüllt für meine Zwecke die Voraussetzungen für PDA. Da kann man viel Gewinn mitspielen, das finde ich sehr persönlich. Das ist so etwas, was ich vom Assistenten erwarten würde.
Du bist aber sehr minimalistisch in deinen Anforderungen.
Da kann ich mir Notizen machen und so über 3400 an meine Mailbox mailen.
Also mailen, kann der richtig popp und so?
Nee, das ist nur so ein SMS-to-E-Mail-Gateway von D2. Das hat ja jeder. Also muss ich einfach die E-Mail-Adresse und dann meinen Text und das ist für mich eine bestimmte Nummer schicken. Oder ich kann halt Rufnummern damit notieren, schnell mal irgendwie Rufnummern austauschen mit denen. Das ist relativ bequem, die Sachen dann einzuspeichern.
Das Ding kostet dort Schweine Geld oder nicht?
Ich hab ein defektes Gerät von der Arbeit mitgenommen. Nein, nicht mitgenommen, sondern zur Verfügung gestellt gekriegt. Also die Kosten, die ich da verursache, die kenn ich gar nicht. Das ist nebenbei auch noch so ein Problem. Ich hab da nicht das Gewissen. Da ist kein Linux drauf auf dem Ding, sondern das ist aber trotzdem ein ziemlich stabiles Betriebssystem. Ich hab glaub ich schon Abtime von 30 Tagen. Load Average ist absolut minimal. Was aber nervt bei dem Ding ist, die haben irgendwie, die waren so stolz darauf, dass das Ding wobbfähig ist, da haben sie gleich vorne auf die Front, also aufs Hauptmenü, haben sie uns so einen Punkt Internet drauf geklebt. Und wenn man das in die Hosentasche steckt und dann den Knopf drückt, und ich hab das nicht in der Gebrauchsanweisung gelesen und manchmal vergiss ich das auch, wie man diesen Tastenschutz anschält, dann geht das Ding ans Internet. Ich hab die Vorführe, auf der nächsten Rechnung wird irgendwie stehen sieben Stunden Internet, obwohl ich das Ding sieben Stunden in der Hosentasche rumgetragen hab. Und das hat selbstständig gebrost.
Aber jetzt mal im Ernst, ich mein, wenn du noch nicht mal Pop 3 damit machen kannst, dann ist das doch eigentlich eher wertlos oder nicht?
Das stimmt, ich muss eigentlich, also ich muss irgendwie mir einen ProcMate AC programmieren auf dem Server, dass die Information so gut filtert, dass es da über WAP geht, dass es mir da neben einer SMS schickt. Mit WAP hat mir ja noch nie jemand eine Schulung gegeben, wie das nicht funktioniert.
Das funktioniert ja auch gar nicht.
Also der Funk ist... Den Funk hatte ich nämlich auch, ja.
Schau mal, wir haben also irgendwie ein PDA so definiert, dass es eigentlich in die Weise ist, was du haben möchtest, also wo du irgendwie alles drauf machen kannst, was du willst. Oder zumindest in der begrenzten Rahmen. Und dieses Siemens-Gerät ist ja sehr limited in seinen Möglichkeiten. Du hast halt irgendwie die Applications, die da drauf sind, die Anwendungen, die du schon mitgekauft hast. Und du hast ein Betriebssystem, was schon in sich komplett ist. Und du kannst aber auch nichts mehr irgendwie erweitern.
Absolut closed und absolut limited. Da gebe ich dir recht, aber dafür ist es stabil und benutzbar. Ich denke, da könnte ich noch ein bisschen an der Ergonomie feilen, aber mehr brauch ich erstmal nicht. Ich muss nicht meine ganzen 20 GB durch die Gegend schleppen. Dafür hab ich meinen Laptop.
Warum soll man nicht in seinem PDA seine Musiksammlung drin haben?
Das ist ein Argument. Ich hab jetzt beim Posten gesehen von Sharp. Gibt es so ein Gerät mit einer ordentlichen QWERTY Tastatur? Habt ihr da mal schon Erfahrungen mit gemacht?
Sharp macht doch auch Windows-D-Geräte, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Oh je, scheiße, jetzt hast du schon gestorben.
Kann man immer noch die Handlungs drauf tun.
Wenn man wenigstens diesen Pocket Outlook wegmachen könnte.
Also, ich muss dir echt raten, wenn du ein benutzbares System haben willst, schau dir einen EPOC an, schau dir einen Palm an.
Ich bin zufrieden mit dem Ding, was ich habe. Das wollte ich natürlich sagen.
Wolltest du nicht, du wolltest Pop 3 haben. Das hast du ganz klar rausgehend. Okay, dann willst du ihm ab.
Ich will meine Ruhe haben und ich will erreichbar sein für die Leute, die bereit sind, ein paar Markzüge auszugeben, denen das so wichtig ist.
Okay, dann sag doch jetzt nochmal deine Nummer.
Ja, könnt ihr gerne haben.
Nicht doch, nicht doch, nicht doch.
Warte mal, warte mal, ich schreibe mit.
Das wird jetzt sonst eine Kontaktbörse. Roman, danke für deinen Handruf. Oh, wir haben hier aus der Ferne Martin. Du rufst also aus Wien an.
Ich ruf aus Wien an, ich grüße euch einmal.
Du hörst dich aber noch vergleichsweise normal an.
Danke.
Keine Ursache.
Ich hab so einen 9110 mir gekauft, 9110i von Nokia.
Was hast du bezahlt?
Ungerechnet, was muss ich sagen? Ich ruf gerade 1200 Mark, circa.
Hättest du da nicht lieber noch drei Tage gewartet und dir den neuen Communicator geholt?
Ich hab mich noch ein bisschen gewartet. Mir wird Dienst eigentlich gereicht. Mich hat von Anfang an interessiert, ob man das Ding programmieren kann und ob man eine Schnittstelle dazu finden kann. Das finde ich sehr gut, dass man damit Talent machen kann. Und FTB, das ist eine unheimliche Arbeitserleichterung. Die sind auch unterwegs. Die Frage ist eher, kann man das Ding auch programmieren?
Auf dem Nokia 11920 heißt das, ne? 11910i. Auf dem läuft ein EPOC-Betriebssystem, beziehungsweise Symbian heißt das. Es gibt dafür einen SDK. Das Problem ist, dass die Dinger nicht gut benutzbar sind. Ich hab mir das nur ganz oberflächlich angeschaut. Du möchtest bei symbian.com oder au oder symbian.de oder symbian.irgendwas anderes vorbeischauen und dir einfach das SDK saugen.
Das ist nicht ganz richtig.
Wer erzählte denn, dass er da mal Turbo Pascal drauf zum Laufen gebracht gekriegt hat? Irgendwer erzählte das, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ne, das war der Portfolio.
War das der Portfolio? Ne, das war ja klar. Irgendwer meinte, äh, um Communicator, Turbo Pascal.
Auf dem 9000er? Ich glaube, da war eine x86 CPU drin. Na, es ist nicht ganz richtig. Symbian ist die Firma, das Betriebssystem ist immer noch epoch.
Ja, ähm, du hast recht.
Ok, wie gesagt, ich danke euch auf jeden Fall für die Information. Lasst uns mal nachschauen und ja.
Machen wir eine kleine Musik zwischendurch. Übrigens, das ist im Hintergrund gerade gemischt von Le Hammond Inferno. Befinde das Schert. Chaosradio 59 und wir haben 23 und 23. Wollte ich nur mal anmerken an dieser Stelle. Ernst verdichtig. Wir reden über PDAs und zwar mit euch. Unsere Nummer ist die 0331 70 97 110. Was benutzt ihr, warum benutzt ihr es und wenn ihr es nicht benutzt, warum benutzt ihr es nicht? Es hat angerufen der Dirk aus Magdeburg.
Hallo.
Ja, das Ding kann, aber die Kohle hat natürlich mal wieder nicht gereicht. Und wollt mal fragen, wie das mit den Einstellungen für die 2 Internet ist, weil das Teil ist noch von vor zwei Änderungen als noch, was war davor, Mann ist Mann und davor war noch was anderes, die 2 privat glaube ich, wie das in DNS-Adressen anzustellen sind, wenn du das für dich wirst.
Da würde ich vorschlagen, da liest du das Handbuch nochmal durch.
Oder ruf wirklich bei D2 an. Genau, Hotline anrufen müssen.
Klarer Fall von Hotline anrufen.
Entsetzte Gesichter, als die sich sagen, ich hab aber nicht die leiste Ahnung.
Okay, okay, ich hab noch ein paar andere Fragen.
Ja, dann tu mal.
Ist die Schnittstelle oder das Display immer an, weil das frisst ganz schön den Akku auf?
Irgendwie hat hier keine Ahnung von dem Communicate, hab ich gerade so ein dumpfes Gefühl. Hallo? Sprecht mal, das hier ist Rundfunk.
Ach, Test?
Dann kann ich dich erledigen.
Okay, vielleicht hast du noch eine Frage. Vielleicht hast du irgendwie... Nach der Uhrzeit.
Da gibt's eine Einstellung, die heißt Auto baut. Wäre das technisch auch möglich, dann mehr als 9, 6K pro Sekunde zu übertragen?
Mit dem nicht.
Wenn die Netze dafür ausgelegt sind?
Na, der kann wahrscheinlich weder HSCSD noch GPRS und deshalb wird das nicht gehen.
Da muss man dazu sagen, dass kein Handy über das GSM-Netzwerk mehr als 9600 baut kann, weil einfach...
Bit pro Sekunde, bitte schön.
Genau, Bit pro Sekunde kann, weil das Netzwerk nicht so viel kann. Das übliche ist 56K Modem an deinem GSM-Handy rankehlen und erwarten, dass das dann funktioniert.
Okay, übrigens läuft das unter Geos und das ist von C64 bekannt, würde ich mal sagen.
Geos-Handy, geil. Ja, Dirk, wir konnten dir leider nicht helfen. Nichts für ungut. Das manchmal ist das Leben hart. Können wir jetzt vielleicht... Bis zur Nachrichten hören wir jetzt mal, was der Erdgeist hier Schönes hören wollte. Achtung, ich dreh mal auf. Ja, mach doch mal, ähm, Talonin, mach das doch mal auf Anfang, bitte, wir. Mach mal auf Anfang. Und der Erdgeist erzählt uns, was es ist.
Das ist Sepultura, Reject von der neuen Platte.
Dann Fritz.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Mitten Wetter, zur Zeit 0 bis 3 Grad, nachts gering bewölkt, Frost bis minus 9 Grad. Die Meldung mit Bastian Burner.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat am Abend einen Eilantrag von Castor-Gegner im Zusammenhang mit den Demonstrationsverboten im Wendland abgelehnt. Dies teilte eine Sprecherin in Karlsruhe mit. Zwei Bürgerinitiativen hatten beantragt, auch innerhalb eines Korridors von 50 Metern links und rechts der Transportstrecke demonstrieren zu dürfen. Der erste Castor-Transport seit vier Jahren wird in Kürze an der französisch-deutschen Grenze erwartet. Im Westjordanland ist ein zehn Monate altes israelisches Baby erschossen worden. Nach Angaben des israelischen Rundfunks hat er ein palästinensischer Heckenschütze in Hebron auf den Vater gefeuert, der das Kind in seinen Armen hielt. In Hebron leben einige hunderte jüdische Siedler unter mehr als 100.000 Arabern. In Ostdeutschland ist die Aktionswoche der niedergelassenen Ärzte angelaufen. Tausende Facharztpraxen blieben geschlossen. Die Mediziner verlangen für dieses Jahr 600 Millionen Mark mehr Honorar für die ambulante Versorgung ihrer Patienten. Sie verweisen darauf, dass sie bisher nur 77 Prozent des Westniveaus bekommen. Ein US-Militärflugzeug ist heute 15 Kilometer östlich von Nürnberg abgestürzt. Die Maschine fiel in ein Waldgelände. Beide Insassen der Propellermaschine. Und der Verkehr Schwed auf der B2 wird gebaut. Ihr müsst mit erheblichen Behinderungen rechnen, wenn möglich einfach den Bereich zwischen Kreisverkehr und der Einfahrt zum Gewerbegebiet meiden.
Danke, ne?
Und wer Crazy Town sehen will, muss Fritz hören. Crazy Town spielen Samstagabend live in der Berliner Columbia Halle.
Für dieses Konzert gibt es keine Karten zu kaufen.
Aber mit Fritz kommt ihr trotzdem rein. Denn Fritz ist das pränzige Radio im ganzen Universum mit 800 Freikarten. Achtung für die Nummer 1.
Chaosradio 59, wir reden über PDAs und zwar mit Björn. Ja, ne?
Geil.
Was war das Talonin-Sachnummer? Er sagt es nachher nochmal. Ja, okay. Er sagt es nachher nochmal.
Also, kennt ihr mal das Frage? Bis vor kurzem hatte ich noch so einen Palmen. Und den hab ich so auf jeden Fall kurzem verkauft, aber ist ja auch egal.
Warum?
Ja, naja, also das ist nicht wirklich so eine tolle Sache irgendwie, weil wenn ich mal aufschreiben will, nehmt einen Notizblock oder so.
Tja, naja, da fährst du doch den Palmen.
Ne, da hab ich aber auch so. Ich hab auch so ein bisschen meine Probleme damit. Also, weil wenn man über einen Notizblock ein Glas Kaffee oder so schüttet, dann funktioniert der Notizblock hinterher immer noch.
Das ist bei meinem Palmen auch so.
Bei deinem? Allerdings ist es einfacher, von einem Palmen einen Backup zu machen als von einem Notizblock.
Das ist richtig.
Was du aus der Tasche ausgeholt hast und so und...
Nicht technophil, du bevorzugst eben analoge Devices. Das ist ja auch okay. Da muss es ja auch Leute geben, die das kaufen.
Nee, aber der hat nur so einen schwarzen Weiß. Also, der M100, sagt er euch was?
Ja, der M100 ist das neueste Device von Palm oder zumindest das...
Ja, unser schlechteste, aber den kann man ja auch nicht mehr updaten irgendwie.
Ja, der sieht erstmal nicht wirklich gut aus. Er hat schon ein höherauflösendes Display dadurch, dass das Display kleiner ist, aber die gleiche Anzahl von Pixel hat. Und er hat dieses feste OS 3.5 drin. Also du möchtest das eigentlich nicht kaufen.
Genau.
Und davon mal abgesehen, also ich mein, man will ja auch was in der Hand halten. Und dieser M100, der sieht aus wie so ein Schlauchboot irgendwie.
Das vor ihren Firmationen, der nennt mich irgendwie an.
Ja, kennt ihr diese Hülle, diese goldene, die es dafür gibt? Das ist ja auch wie Mistkäfer mit.
Ja, dazu sollste sagen, aus der Presse mal vom Palm geht hervor. Die erfolgreiche Palm M100-Serie spricht speziell Frauen. Neuersteiger bla bla bla an. Also das erklärt eventuell auch zum Teil das Design, was sich der App ausgeliefert hat.
Also, Björn, du bist ganz klar nicht die Zielgruppe.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, nee. Aber ich interessiere mich so ein bisschen im Moment für den Compaq iPack.
Okay, warte mal, ich muss mal kurz meinen Kopfhörer wechseln.
Genau, ja, iPack Fachmann Erdgeist.
Ja, ich hab dir da vorhin so ein bisschen abwertend über das Windows CE System gesprochen, ne?
Es ist schon nicht ungeil, aber es ist von einer falschen Firma einfach.
Ich finde gerade Pocket Outlook kotzt mich an.
Echt?
Ja, der sagt mir noch nicht mal, wie viele Mails auf dem Pop-Server rumliegen, sondern der lädt die einfach mal alle runter und irgendwann ist er fertig. Dann sagt er aber auch nicht, dass er fertig ist. Nein, noch nicht mehr in Prozent. Da steht gar nichts. Da steht unten und drinnen jetzt hier Nachricht 1, Nachricht 2, Nachricht 3. Warten, warten, warten. Ich finde gerade Pocket Outlook schlimm.
Ihr kriegt einfach zu viele Mails.
Ja, aber dafür sind sie doch da.
Tut uns leid.
Du hast doch noch eine Frage dazu.
Das kommt drauf an. Eine Lösung, die ich empfehlen würde, das hängt davon ab, wie viel du basteln möchtest, auf dem iPad irgendwann mal ein Linux zu installieren und da den X-Core-Pilot zu installieren. Dann kannst du nämlich die Pilot-Anwendungen auf...
Die waren ja ganz irgendwie... Ja, und wir entwerfen irgendwie so ein GSM-Modul und so, dann kannst du damit auch telefonieren. Also, das wäre nett angehört, aber ob das dann wirklich kommt, ist auch so eine Frage, was?
Ja, ich denke, wir werden das schon machen. Sehr erfolgreiches Gerät.
Mit dem PC-MCA-Cradle kannst du doch jetzt schon ein Cardphone reinstecken, das hast du zumindest schon mal im Internet. Und denkbar wäre, dass du darüber auch ganz normal telefonieren kannst, weil bei dem iPad ist das Mikro und der Lautsprecher genau so angebracht, dass du die auch wie ein Telefon an die Backe halten kannst und damit theoretisch telefonieren kannst.
An die Backe? An die Wange, ne?
An die Backe auch.
Na ja, obwohl, wo man sich dieses Windows-CE hinstecken kann. Na ja, also ich mein, ich hab mir das ja auch mal angeguckt. Ich hatte mal eine Zeit lang so ein NEC-Gerät, das sieht so ähnlich aus wie der John Nader, ein bisschen größer. Das ist schon alles nett gemacht, da ist irgendwie ein Excel drin und Word, da ist sogar ein Powerup drin. Und das Problem ist aber, dieses Gerät hat innerhalb der ersten 5 Minuten 3-mal meinen Namen vergessen und da kann ich irgendwie meine Termine nicht reintun in so ein Ding.
Das ist etwas ärgerlich. Ja, was mich da dran so ein bisschen stört in diesem Windows-CE ist, du kannst nichts rausschmeißen, weil ich brauche keinen Excel und ich brauche keinen Powerpoint. Und das würde ich ganz gerne einfach darunter kanten und den Speicher frei machen, das geht eben nicht.
Ja, es geht mit viel Basteln bestimmen, aber es ist nicht einfach, man kann nicht auf den Knopf drücken.
Eben.
Ja, was mich an diesem Teil irgendwie so gereizt hat ist, dass man Videos angucken kann. Also das M100 war einfach mehr so eine Einsteigergeschichte. Das hat der Typ da auch gesagt, was ich gekauft hab. Und das ist ein bisschen wapp da.
Naja, und Video bei den 8MB, die da drin sind.
Ich kann dir empfehlen, Waveline über den Cradle, also so eine Schale hinten, die Waveline-Card reinstecken und kannst dir über das Netzwerk, meinetwegen auch Samba, Filme laden und in Echtzeit abspielen.
Oder so als Walkman in der Wohnung einfach die MP3s vom Server dann über Filesharing auf dem iPack abspielen, Kopfhörer anschließen, geht prima.
Auch schon gemacht.
Ja, nö, das war's dann eigentlich.
Danke für deinen Anruf. Oh, einen haben wir noch. Du hast auch noch eine Frage zum Paar.
Ich hab immer noch benutzt.
Hast du auch das coole Fax-Modem?
Nee, ich hab kein Modem mehr.
Ich hab nämlich beim Aufräumen noch ein Newton-Fax-Modem gefunden, also das nur senden kann.
Ich hab's überlegt, mir mal zuzuhören, aber das bringt nichts. Das perren vor die Säue so wenig, wie ich rumfaxe. Stimmt. Na gut, aber es ist ein trauriges Auge, wenn man guckt, was so möglich ist. Ich arbeite viel mit Freimaker und mach da auch allerhand auf dem Mac mit. Da bietet sich natürlich Palm an, weil die jetzt eine Version bringen, die auf dem Palm läuft, die ist schon da, wie ich jetzt gehört hab, vom Freimaker Magazin. Da wir die Frage, ob ihr schon mal Erfahrung gemacht habt, mit Freimaker und Palm. Also nicht, schade.
Ja, also Freimaker ist, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, so ein Datenorganisierungstool auf dem Mac. Ist das richtig?
Das ist eine fortgeschrittene Datenbank mit grafischem Interface zum Zusammenklicken.
Sogar relational dann irgendwann mal geworden.
Ja, das ist schon eine feine Sache. Und das ist eben kompatibel mit Dosen und Äpfeln.
Also es gibt einige relationale Datenbanken auf dem Palm. Also die scheinen auf jeden Fall alle zu funktionieren. Und ich denke mal, wenn das rauskommt, du meinst ja, das kommt bald raus, werden wir es auf jeden Fall uns angucken und dann dazu mehr sagen können. Also was ich dir empfehlen kann, ist so eine Open Source Datenbank, die glaube ich auch relational kann. Die gibt es oder Henning Go. Und ja, wie gesagt, die ist empfehlenswert. Du kannst ja auch im Prinzip deine Felder zusammen klicken oder zusammen wählen und dort dann die Daten so speichern, dann mit Windows- oder Mac-Software abgleichen.
Gut, dann hab ich noch eine Frage, die mir gerade durch den Kopf schießt. Ist einfach diese Erfahrung, so gesagt, mit dem Datenabgleich Hotsink, welche Erfahrungen ihr gemacht habt mit einer URDA Schnittstelle? Ob das wirklich, also ich werde so auf Hanspring gucken, das ist so für mich der Punkt, wo ich sage, das ist so Mac-Lite, da komm ich noch klar, wenn ich meinen Newton weggebe, dann sitze ich so ganz kalt in meiner Hosentasche, wenn der Hanspring da wäre.
Na, obwohl, der verbraucht ein bisschen weniger Strom, also das wird schon ein bisschen kühler werden.
Die Frage ist einfach...
Mit einzelnen Worten, während ich rede.
Ja, die URDA Schnittstelle, das wollte ich wissen, welche Fragen ihr da gemacht habt.
Ja, also die URDA Schnittstelle funktioniert auf dem Palm. Was das überraschendste oder was irgendwie ein echt cooles Feature ist, ist, dass du eine Fernseh, also Fernsehfernbedienung drauf emulieren kannst. Gehst du also in einen Fernsehladen, lässt dir dann den Fernseher mal kurz vorführen, schaltest in den Lernmodus nebenbei und kannst dann die Fernseher irgendwie fernbedienen. Das ist... Es gab da glaube ich mal so ein paar Leute, die auf der C mit rumgelaufen sind, haben dann die ganzen LCD-Bandschirme ausgeschaltet, bei URDA.
Nee, aber die funktionierte sehr, sehr gut. Also bevor ich die Schere da ins Display...
Das Einzige, was bei mir immer funktionierte, war das URDA-Ping. Da gab es so ein Debugging-Tool, das ist an der Seite, und leider will das Nokia-Handy dann nicht mit mir irgendwas reden.
Inzwischen können die das sogar.
URDA klappt.
Ohne Kabel, ohne alles.
Also der Punkt ist, die URDA steht still, du hast halt einen Meter Reichweite ungefähr, und du solltest das nicht in direktem Sonnenlicht machen, weil dann ist einfach... Die LED kommt dann nicht gegen die Sonne an, aber selbst da kannst du im Prinzip, wenn du das Handy direkt daneben legst, arbeiten.
Ja gut, bei mir geht's ums Powerbook, dass ich das ein bisschen abgleichen kann.
Also es funktioniert, du kannst auch irgendwie Horsenken bei URDA machen, das klappt auf jeden Fall. Gut.
Jürgen, danke für deinen Anruf.
Wenn ihr da wieder neuen Moon macht, dann frag ich mal nach Fahlmecke nochmal nach. Alles klar.
Alles gut Jürgen, tschüss. Ihr Chaosradio 59, unser Thema sind die PDAs.
Ah, das ist Wahnsinn.
So, Talunil wird jetzt mal sagen, was wir hier die ganze Zeit hören.
Die meiste Zeit läuft hier Musik, die aufgenommen wurde von einem Stream im Internet, von einem MPEG-Stream. Im Genauzein sind es zwei. Die heißen GoaBlaze und Digitally Imported. Wir haben www.digitally.com und www.goablaze.org. Danke nochmal an die Produzenten von den Streams.
So, Chaosradio 59. Und wir reden über PDAs.
Es heißt ja jetzt inzwischen M-Commerce.
Heute hab ich gelesen B2C, also Business to Customer, würden sie im Silicon Valley jetzt übersetzen mit Back to Cleveland, weil so eine Arbeit losgebrochen ist.
Jetzt fragt sich nur noch, dass eine neue Erfindung für irgendwie B2B kommt. Wenn B2B inzwischen out ist, was kommt danach?
Ja, also mit dabei hier beim Chaosradio sind unter anderem Jinja, der...
Hallo!
der auch in irk.cdc.de auf dem Irkserver im Channel Chaosradio zu finden ist.
Ja, unter Wetters Nickname sozusagen.
Hacker.
Mit dabei ist der Stuttgarter Teil.
Ey, nicht Stuttgart, ja.
Ein Ausländer quasi.
Nee, Stuttgart.
Und dann kommt noch andere Gestalten rum.
Gungeon.
Das ist Gungeon.
Ganz schön. Aus dem tummeln sich da hinten noch Andreas und der Erdgeist auf der Herde.
Und hinter dem Pult der Holger.
Ach ja genau, ich heiß Holger. Holger?
Willkommen zu Hack the Planet, die Sendung über den ETA.
Hack da Planet, genau.
Also bei uns geht es um Handhelds. Wenn ihr uns mitteilen wollt, wie ihr ein Furby am besten mit dem Palm steuert, ruft doch einfach mal an.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 90, 110.
Chaosradio 59 auf Fritz, kurz vor Mitternacht. Was hatten wir? Irda wollten wir noch näher drauf eingehen. Weil wir reden ja über PDAs, über Personal Digital Assistant.
Holger, du lernst das Wort heute auch noch.
Ich hab geübt.
Peridural Anästhesie.
Peridural Anästhesie, natürlich.
Das war vor der Rap-Camp, seht ihr übrigens Zero Cool.
Genau, das ist Zero Cool, der 1507 Systeme an einem Tag zum Absturz gebracht hat.
Also, wir haben ja als Thema Handhelds, PDAs und andere Kleinigkeiten mit Elektronik drin. Und die möchten natürlich immer kommunizieren, und zwar sehr aktiv. Was natürlich böse Stimmen, die behaupten, Bluetooth wär tot. Aber das Konzept von Bluetooth ist ja schon etwas älter. Das hat jedes Laptop heutzutage außer den iBooks. Die haben es halt nicht mehr. Und zwar ist das IA-DA. Das ist auch echt billig herzustellen. Da hast du also zwei Lampen, zwei LEDs drin, ein IC. Und dann kannst du damit irgendwie Datenabgleich oder Kommunikation machen. Das hat also auch jeder fernsteuerbare Fernseher. Wer das also nicht kennt.
Außer die alten. Die alten Fernseher hatten noch Ultraschall. Kennst du das noch? Die ganz alten, ganz alte Fernbedienung ging mit Ultraschall. Das war total abgefahren.
Ich erinnere mich an einen Fernseher mit Kabelfernbedienung.
Ja, das ist ja eh. Aber das mit Ultraschall das coole war, wenn du einen Schlüsselbund genommen hast und vor dem Empfangsteil am Fernseher mit dem Schlüsselbund gerasselt hast, hat der umgeschaltet.
Zu Fernseher messen.
Das ist richtig, ja. Und den Hund verrückt machen.
Ja, also EDA ist ein Serialist-Protokoll, das läuft eben über dieses Infrarot. Und das spricht eigentlich jedes, die weiß, was irgendwie Infrarot hat. Das haben allerdings die Parmleute irgendwie vergessen, als sie die Infrarot-Schnittstellen in ihren Parmen eingebaut haben. Das gab es also nur noch als Update für das Betriebssystem. Und wenn man also dieses Update hatte, konnte man EDA machen vorher nicht.
Version 3.3?
Genau, Version 3.3. Ja, und für alle Glücklichen unter euch, die ein Nokia 6120 haben oder ein 6150 oder ein 6110, damit geht es doch auch nicht, oder nicht? Genau, damit geht es nicht.
Die sind insofern für Internet schreiben und dann emuliert diese Software halt ein Modem und das geht halt über das Handy online. Diese Software gibt es für Palm nicht, es gibt aber ein Zwischenstück für 300 Dollar oder so, irgendwie viel Geld.
Ja, naja, nicht wirklich teuer. Also es gibt von TDK so ein Softmodem, das läuft auf Windows-C-Geräten und auf Palm und TDK hatte sich irgendwie ihren Server nicht ganz sauber hingekriegt, also unter dem Support-Bereich konnte man sich zumindest die Palm-Version für die Ericsson und Nokia-Telefone kostenlos runtersaugen als Update quasi. Es war eigentlich genau eine Vollversion. Und naja, also wenn das immer noch so der Fall sein sollte, wer immer noch ein Nokia 6120-Handy haben sollte, geht jetzt bitte bei TDK einkaufen.
Man muss allerdings noch dieser Name eingebürgert. Es geht da eigentlich nur darum, AT-Commandos zu verstehen, weil der Rechner gerne mit AT-Commandos wählen muss und dann muss diese Telefonnummer in ein anderes Paketformat umgepackt werden und da reingeschoben werden. Also da 300 Mark fürzunehmen ist schlicht und ergreifend Beutelschneiderei. Ich war auch im Spiegel vor zwei Wochen glaube ich ein prima Artikel drüber über inkompatible Stecker und 200 verschiedene Typen Staubsaugerbeutel und die Methoden, mit denen die Industrie ihre Kunden quält und ausbeutet.
Ja natürlich, also irgendjemand meinte mal, oder in ihrem Artikel stand, dass die Konsolenhersteller, also Nintendo und Sega und Sony und so weiter, den größten Umsatz eigentlich mit Controllern und Memory Cards und Spielmodulen machen und nicht mit den Geräten selber. Und ich mein, das ist ganz klar, wenn die da irgendwie in Garage gehen und selber löten.
Also wo wir jetzt so ziemlich beim Thema Infrarot sind, gibt es noch was interessantes, nämlich Wavelan. Haben die in dieser Sendung noch nicht wirklich erwähnt?
Nee, also Wavelan ist Lan über Wave. So, jetzt ist es erwähnt.
Und der Standard schreibt auch vor, dass Wavelan, eben 11M mit über Funk, auch über Infrarot möglich sein soll. Und interessant wäre, eigentlich, habe ich bislang noch nicht gefunden, ich weiß nicht, weißt du was davon? Eine Software, die halt über Infrarot 802.11b, so heißt der Wavelan-Standard, spricht. Das wäre mal ein interessantes Projekt.
Ja, das können wir ja mal machen. Also auf dem Palm ist mir davon noch nichts bekannt, aber als ich mir den Palm neu gekauft hatte, hatte ich mir überlegt, hey, da müsste es doch irgendwie Ethernet werden.
Jetzt müssen wir einen Chip machen. Die Geräte von Palm sind an sich nicht fähig, TCP-IP zu sprechen, weil sie nicht diese Performance dazu haben. Deswegen wäre dafür dann also TCP-IP so mit richtig Ethernet dran. Es gibt zwar ein bisschen C Adapter, aber der Treiber für NE-2000-kontaktive Karten ist seit einem Jahr in Arbeit. Ich weiß nicht, ob da noch was kommt.
Also laut Hand-Era, beziehungsweise früher TRG Pro, arbeiten sie ständig dran. Allerdings war das Problem, dass Palm kein echtes Multitasking macht. Und für Ethernet brauchst du einfach mal Multitasking. Wenn du das auf einem Handheld machst, der eben kein Multitasking spricht, dann geht das nicht.
Wobei man entfällt, so ein Palm-eignet... Nee, ein Palm nicht, aber ein iPad eignet sich ja auch prima als Wanze. Ist nicht besonders groß. Hat denn irgendwie der abzuhörende Waveline, den man nicht hinfahren muss und ein Gerät anschließen?
Das diskutieren wir gesondert gerade mal. Oh, es ist Mitternacht. Und zwar das Chaosradio Nummer 59, PDAs Personal Digital Assistance in unser Thema heute Abend. Chaosradio 59 mit Handhelds. Ihr redet immer über Programmieren. Ich mein, was will ich denn da programmieren? Ich will, dass da meine Adressen drin sind und dass der verdammt noch mal web macht. Und ein bisschen E-Mail.
Also, man möchte, viele Leute müssen das natürlich nicht programmieren, aber wir wollen das natürlich programmieren, weil es sich um Computer handelt und man Computer programmieren kann.
Achso, warum leckt der Hund sich die Eier?
Genau, es ist die Befriedigung eines Grundbedürfnisses.
Weil er kann.
Mit anderen Worten.
Na ja, Computer definieren sich doch dadurch, dass sie programmierbar sind. Sonst sind das ja keine Computer.
Aber es hat auch für Anwender einen Effekt, wenn es sehr, sehr einfach ist, für eine Plattform Software zu schreiben, dann setzen sich natürlich auch mehr Leute hin und schreiben dafür Software. Das existiert nur, weil es dafür eine kostenlose Entwicklungsumgebung gibt.
Genau.
Das wiederum sorgt wieder dafür, dass mehr User diesen Palm auch benutzen, was natürlich der Firma auch wieder mehr abgesetzte Geräte bringt. Das macht Microsoft zurzeit genauso. Die stellt die Entwicklungsumgebung für WinCE kostenlos im Netz zur Verfügung. Kann man sich runterladen, kann man zuhause programmieren.
Da gibt es auch den absurdesten Kram für WinCE, hab ich gesehen. Also wirklich Doom Quake, also für WinCE.
Auf dem Ipack dumm zu spielen, macht Laune.
Kann ich mir vorstellen, das ist vor allem cooler als bei jedem scheiß Gameboy.
Auf jeden Fall.
Dazu muss ich sagen, so was ähnliches wie Doom gibt es halt für ein Palm, da hast du Infrarot, kannst du andere Leute abschießen. Wenn sie abgeschossen sind, dann piept das Ding halt einmal laut und deutlich an.
Das ist hübsch, wie damals die PC64 Spiele.
Electro-Gotcha, ja.
Genau, Electro-Gotcha. Ja, also Entwicklung und wofür kann man es machen? Auf dem Palm. Ja, also wie gesagt, der Palm hat einen 68.000er Prozessor, dafür existierte ja schon lange für den Mac der entsprechende GCC-Compiler und man konnte dafür also fröhlich loscoden. Das Problem war natürlich, dass man irgendwie nicht einfach in Assembler irgendwie Software schreiben kann und dann läuft sie einfach, sondern dieses Palm OS braucht eine bestimmte Funktion, wo das Ding halt irgendwie ins Programm reinkommt und dann wieder rausgeht. Event-Händler und so was und so weiter. Da gibt es halt auch schöne Templates dafür, die kann man verwenden und dann kann man einfach direkt loscoden.
Allerdings hätte Richard Stormin dich gesteinigt, weil der Apple Macintosh der hatte noch so lange eben gesteinigt oder nicht? auf der Boycott-Liste von Richard Stormin stand wegen der Geschichte mit dem Patent auf dem Papierkorb und so weiter und so fort. Also liefen auch früher viele Unix-Systeme und daher kommt der GCC-Support.
Also betrachte mich jetzt als gesteinigt.
Von Stormin gesteinigt.
Von Stormin gesteinigt, genau. Hat er eine E-Mail-Adresse?
Ja, rmsatgnu.org.
Genau.
Okay, ich schreib ihm mal.
Mach das mal, schön groß. Ich hätte immer noch jemandem rauchen aufgehört.
Okay, also man kann sich diesen GCC-Compiler für Windows und für Unix kostenlos aus dem Internet holen und losprogrammieren. Es gibt sogar Object-Oriented Libraries dafür. Was heißt?
Das erklärst mir.
Dir? Du verstehst das eh nicht. Nein, Object-Oriented heißt, dass du nicht wie ein normales Programm bist ja so aufgebaut machst etwas, dann fragst du den User, ob er weitermachen will oder ob er beenden möchte. Und wenn er beenden möchte, beendet sich das Programm so. Das ist die grundsätzliche Programmierarbeit, die halt normalerweise man in der Schule lernt. Und dann gibt es halt diese hypermodernen Programmiertechniken, wo du dann sagst, hey, das ist ja nicht irgendwie ein paar Pixel auf dem Bildschirm, sondern das ist ein Objekt. Und dieses Objekt hat Eigenschaften und hat Methoden. Und je nachdem was das für ein Objekt ist, hat das halt bestimmte Methoden und bestimmte Eigenschaften. Und da fällt mir dazu übrigens ein Witz ein. Also wie fängt ein C-Programmierer ein, ein Elefanten und ein C-Plus-Plus-Programmierer ein Elefanten.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, ein C-Programmierer läuft die ganze Wüste ab und irgendwie, um zu hören, ob da ein Elefant drin sitzt und ein C-Plus-Plus-Programmierer ruft einfach die Methode fang dich auf.
Naja, fällt mir auch noch ein Witz mit Elefanten. Dann soll ich den auch erzählen.
Ach, der ins Fenster kommt.
Der mit dem Elefanten, den Krokodilen und den Affen?
Nee, also ein Typ läuft durch die Wüste, ne? Hört auf einmal so ein Tröt, ein Tröt, Tröt, kommt um die Ecke, ist ein Elefant, ein riesen Stachel im Hintern. Der zieht den Stachel raus, der Elefant freut sich, total happy, trötet rum, läuft weg. 15 Jahre später, der Typ sitzt im Zirkus, in der Elefantennummer. Guckt sich die Elefantennummer an, der Dompteur macht mit dem Elefant rum, der Elefant bleibt stehen, guckt den Typen, man rennt zu dem Typen hin und tritt den platt. War ein anderer Elefant. Entschuldigung. Ja, bitte, können wir die billigen Lacher mal eingespielt haben? Bitte weiter mit Handhelds, ich glaube, das ist...
Also hier sagt gerade jemand, dass es GCC auch für Epoch bei Symbian auf der C-Bit gibt, wenn also unbedingt jemand hin möchte, kostenlos abzuholen.
Ja, und bei Microsoft gibt es auch diesen Browser, kostenlos.
Dann möchte man kostenlos wieder weg haben.
Da wo wir bei der C-Bit gerade sind, wurde vorhin noch mal noch der Ur gefragt, von morgen auf dem Siemens-Stadt um 16 Uhr. Und die Url ist http.doppel.doppelslash kellen mit oe.ccc.de slash projekte mit k slash ccc e-Bit Und was wird dann da passieren? Da werden Filtermaßnahmen...
Was?
Filtermaßnahmen werden ergriffen.
Filtermaßnahmen werden ergriffen? Kannst du das etwas ausführen? Ich hab keine Zeit dahin zu gehen. Ich bin da. Diese Computer, immer von denen die Musik kommt. Irgendwie ist das alles. Chaosradio 59, guten Abend.
Jo, wir sind gerade auf eine prima Idee gekommen und zwar ist uns diese alte Fernsehserie Max Hedrum eingefallen, wo der Typ da mit der Kamera auf der Schulter rumrennt und die Kamera sendet einfach direkt.
Man kann das live sehen.
Und naja, so was kann man ja mit seinem Mobile Device im Prinzip auch basteln. Also wahrscheinlich, wenn die Bitraten mal ein bisschen mehr werden, kann man mal mit Audio anfangen und dann mit UMTS, vielleicht auch mal Video. Aber im Prinzip heißt das, dass jeder zum Sender wird und jeder Live-Berichterstattung machen kann. Und die Konsequenzen dafür werden sicherlich für Sportübertragungsrechte genauso verheerend werden, wie die Konsequenzen momentan in der Musik- und in der Filmindustrie durch CD- und DVD-Kopiererei sind. Das wird ein Spaß. Und Greenpeace macht das ja schon lange. Die haben Aktionen gemacht, sind sie irgendwie durch die Nordsee gefahren und wurden von der russischen Marine aufgebracht und dann kam die russische Marine an Bord, Greenpeace filmte das alles, kam die russische Marine an Bord und wollte die Tapes beschlagnahmen. Es gab aber gar keine Tapes, weil nämlich die Satelliten-Ablinks-Strecke da war und das Video einfach direkt gesendet wurde und es gab dann ein Backup in Hamburg, wo die Technik stand.
Dumm gelaufen.
Schön gelaufen.
Ja, also gerade bei der Cebit, wo überall Waveline ist, ist das doch schon möglich, oder nicht? Da ist das sicherlich problemlos möglich.
Ja, das verzeiht nur das Problem, dass man an die iPad Cradles nur eine PCMCA-Karte reinstecken kann. Da kann man sich überlegen, ob man da eine Kamera anschließt oder eine WF-Karte. Na, eine USB-Kamera müsste TV-dischminieren.
Ok, dann so ein kleines Vaio. Es gibt doch ein Vaio mit einer Kamera oben drin.
Das wäre es eigentlich dafür. Das wäre das Ding.
Das ist übrigens auch schon fast Kategorie Handheld-Computer von der Größe her. Also wer die nicht kennt, die sind so groß wie eine VHS-Kassette wiegen einen Kilo, haben einen 1024 x 640 Display und es ist ein richtiger PC drin.
Aber da reden wir auch über 5000 Mark, oder?
Ja, so was, so viereinhalb. Aber IBM Notebookskosten, das doppelte von dem, was Vaio Notebookskosten. Also es ist noch relativ zivil vergleichsweise.
Bewegliche Teile.
Bewegliche Teile. Ich hab ja keine bewegliche Teile. Also wie ist denn, ich hab so einen Jornada, Juliet Packert, also mit kleiner Tastatur, weil ich dachte mir, ich will wenigstens ein Display haben, dass ich nicht rechts, links scrollen muss. Ist das empfehlenswertes Gerät oder hab ich mal wieder in die Scheiße gegriffen?
Also ich hör über den Jornada irgendwie in letzter Zeit nur Gutes, aber ich hab einen Z50 und bin immer zufrieden.
Du hast was?
Einen Z50.
Achso, das war dieses...
Ich find das Jornada auch okay, also ich brauch auf jeden Fall eine Tastatur und sowas, um irgendwie was tippen zu können. Und das ist so ziemlich das kleines Gerät mit einstelligen Tastaturen, wo man auch ein richtiges Betriebssystem drauf wagen kann, wenn man das vorinstallierte runternimmt.
Falls man es schafft, das runterzunehmen, ja.
Genau. In der anderen Richtung haben sie es auch geschafft, in Armbanduhr einen Computer einzubauen, der auf den Linux fährt. Sogar mit Farbisplay jetzt. Kann man auf Heise mal suchen.
Batterielebensdauer 30 Minuten.
Ach, darauf kommt es noch nicht an. Das ist ein Spielzeug. Man möchte es nicht benutzen.
Doch, eigentlich ja schon.
Eigentlich schon. Eigentlich wäre es schön, wenn das alles 200 Mark kosten würde, funktionieren würde und den ganzen Tag halten würde.
Chaosradio 59, genau, danach kommen wir zum Programmieren zurück. Danach heißt, nachdem wir mit Gerson gesprochen haben, diese Sendung ist zum Anrufen, 031 70 97 110. Hallo Gerson.
Ja, hallo. Ich hab noch eine Frage zum IADA. Und zwar habt ihr vorhin erzählt, dass man mit irgendwelchen Palms eine Fernbedienungfunktion benutzen kann.
Genau.
War das der Palm direkt oder was?
Das ist Palm und die Software heißt Omni Remote.
Das ist eine von vielen.
Eine von vielen, ja gut.
Palm Remote glaube ich, die ist dann eine andere sehr beliebte.
Also ich hatte Omni, die hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Also die funktionieren eh alle nach dem selben Profil.
Von der ging aber das Gerücht, dass sie die Endstufe kaputt macht, weil sie ganz komische Dinge mit der LED macht, aber ich glaube, dass ist nicht wahr.
Keine Ahnung, also...
Es gibt auch Irrevieren, die da eine Badewanne befüllen und dann irgendwie Katzen reinschmeißen oder so.
Legionellen.
Ja, noch eine Frage.
Wo es denn da denn da sind, wenn das nur eine Meter Reichweite hat?
Ja, das hat es doch nur, wenn wir einen starken Sonnenschein haben. Also man kann zwei Meter... Ich glaube, das Entscheid ist ja, dass du die zwei Geräte nebeneinander legen möchtest und ohne da großartig mit Kabeln rumzufummeln, Daten abweichen kannst. Also du kannst dein PDA vor deinem Laptop legen und einfach da das Daten synchronisieren, ohne dass du da Kabel umschleppen kannst.
Aber für die Fernbedienungsfunktion würden wir ja schon mehr Reichweite haben. Das hatten die alten Nachrüstplatine, also wenn noch jemand die Nachrüstplatine für den Palm 3 hat, oder den Palm Professional, die hatte fünf Meter Reichweite.
Ansonsten gibt es nämlich noch so kleine Module, die du unten an deinem Palm klemmen kannst, die haben dann auch echt viel Reichweite. Die sind auch von Omni Remote irgendwie supported und dann kannst du da einfach zehn Meter Reichweite kriegen oder so. Also die haben da echt starke LEDs reingebaut.
Aber eigentlich war die Erstenstelle nicht dafür da, um Fernbedienung zu ersetzen.
Habt ihr Erfahrung für einen Handspring? Wie weit der reicht?
Na das sind auch... Also beim Handspring ist die LED irgendwie an der Seite, das heißt du möchtest damit auch nicht wirklich irgendwie was steuern, weil du dann den Handspring irgendwie drehen musst. Und ansonsten, also die LEDs sind vom Typ her ähnlich, das wird auch nicht viel stärker sein.
Ja, ich hatte die Idee über eine Funkübertragung dann auf dem Rechner zuzugreifen und dann mp3s meinetwegen...
Ja, dazu wurde halt extra für PDAs Bluetooth entwickelt. Das reicht halt, hat auch einen Meter über Funk, 2, 4 Gigahertz wie Wavelan. Und ist halt dafür praktisch, wenn man ein Headset haben will, ohne Kabel oder für sein PDA eine Tastatur, das sind alles Anwendungsgebiete von Bluetooth.
Na ja, nur dummerweise gibt es das ganze Zuge, meistens auch nicht.
Aber ich bin gerade dabei, also auf der CeBit wird irgendwie fleißig präsentiert.
Letztes Jahr waren sie auch schon dabei.
Also, was man nicht im Laden kaufen kann, gibt es nicht. Und ich kenne aber jemanden, der tatsächlich seinen Fernseher mit einem iPad, mit einer Wavelan-Karte drin fernbedient. Das ist jetzt ziemlich die dekadenteste Fernbedienung, die ich mir vorstellen kann. Und das funktioniert aber prima. Da kann man sich dann ein kleines Webinterface verschreiben, oder was auch immer, und dann seine Aufnahmen damit steuern.
Kostet aber einen Haufen Geld, um sich so eine Fernbedienung zu basteln.
Geld ist uninteressant.
Solange man genug davon hat, schon. Ja, noch eine Frage oder? Nee, das war's.
Das war's? Da gibt es einen Anruf.
Haben wir noch Anrufer?
Im Moment nicht. 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer, falls noch Anrufer anrufen wollen. Wir sind die Service-Nummer zur Cebit.
Nein, das ist nicht wahr. Handheld Service-Nummer. Die Aussteller-Hotline auf der Cebit ist die 0511 890. Also wenn ihr irgendwelche interessanten Probleme habt, die ihr kreativ lösen wollt, ist das die Telefonnummer der Wahl.
Ja.
Sucht euch einfach irgendeinen Stand aus dem Katalog raus, von dem ihr behauptet, ihr seid das, und dann kann man da Dienstleistung anfordern.
Genau, und falls ihr gucken wollt, wie mein Partner Steffen Halaschka seine Seele verkauft, dann geht's zu Siemens zum Stand Mobile Technologies. Da verkauft er gerade seine Seele.
Ansonsten, wenn ihr irgendwie gerne auf die Seele wollt und nicht so viel Geld habt, kauft euch eine Pizza und sagt ihr möchtet liefern. Also der Liefereingang funktioniert ganz unproblematisch.
Der ist wo?
Der ist West 2, glaube ich.
Also der Haupt...
Moment mal, das ist jetzt nicht dein Ernst. Du kommst da wirklich mit einer Pizza durch.
Du kommst mit einer Pizza durch und sagst, hey, Nokia hat irgendwie Pizza bestellt, du hast dann eine Stunde Zeit, die Pizza anzuliefern, und nach einer Stunde kostet die andere eine neue Pizza.
Das ist ja cool. Aber wieso solltest du dir eine neue Pizza holen, dann bist du da drin.
Du musst noch mal eine liefern.
Das Problem ist, du hast halt irgendwie 100 Mark Pfand. Wenn du also drin bleibst, dann sind die 100 Mark verloren. Wenn du rausgehst und eine neue Pizza kaufst, dann hast du halt immer deine 100 Mark.
Wie viele Pizzen sind das pro Tag? Was kostet eine Pizza?
Kannst du wirklich eine Pizza in einer Schachtel sein? Reicht das nicht aus?
Es reicht eigentlich auch eine Schachtel. Also ich hänge halt davon ab, wie alt und erfahren der Mensch ist, der da irgendwie am Eingang ist.
In Notfallsholz klaust du dir irgendwo so ein Brezelkorb in Berlin.
Überleben kann man ziemlich gut. Es gibt da dieses Kongresszentrum, dieses TCM, und da machen Firmen Vorträge für ihre Kunden, wo sie dann zu einladen und dann ihr Produkt vorstellen. Da werden Schnittchen gereicht. Und wenn man in der Lage ist, halbwegs unauffällig zu sein, also man sollte da nicht mit Tüten behangen hingehen, sondern sollte schon so aussehen, als wäre man interessierter Fachbesucher, dann kann man da Schnittchen abgreifen.
Ja und wer vielleicht Leute von seiner Schülerzeitung kennt, die mal fragen, ob sie im Impressum drinstehen für das nächste Jahr dann. Oder irgendwie andere Pressemöglichkeiten bei die Presse. Pressekonferenzen gibt es immer was zu trinken. Pressebranche jeden Morgen. Und das reicht eigentlich als Tagesaufregung.
Ansonsten, um den Tag sinnvoll zu beenden, gibt es immer diese gerühmten Messeparties unter z.B.
Stuntparties.de oder heise.de Stunt und Sega hat sich die Erlaubnis geholt, jeden Abend eine Party machen zu dürfen. Und da gab es immer hektoliterweise Kalpirinias.
Und seitdem sind die pleite.
Das war die Kohle für den Hohlemstil in Kiefer.
Dieses Jahr eine. Dann würde uns mal interessieren, ob Sega wieder Kalpirinias rumschmeißt.
Ich werde Bescheid sagen. Wir sagen euch dann auch, wie man Modems in diese Dreamcast einbaut. Kommen wir vielleicht noch mal zur Programmierung. Wollten wir nicht noch über Programmierung reden?
Wir wollten eigentlich über Programmierung reden, aber wir schweifen die ganze Zeit.
Den Psyon gibt es zum Beispiel noch. Der kommt ja auch mit so einer komischen eingebauten Programmierung. Ja, da gibt es dort diese Programmiersprache, mit der sich bestimmte Tätigkeiten sehr toll scripten lassen. Und natürlich kann man damit auch eigene Applikationen erstellen. Zu sagen, bleibt heißen tut die Sprache OPL?
Nein, weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, wie sie heißt.
Die Sprache heißt, Moment. Ich glaube, sie heißt wirklich OPL 3 oder so.
Kann man damit auch richtig nette Sachen machen oder nur so...
Nein, man kann ganz einfach...
OPL 3 ist Welt hier online.
Nein, ganz einfach kann man scripten. So, wenn man ein bisschen das Handbuch studiert und wenn man das Programming-How-To dann noch liest, dann kann man auch richtig irgendwie alle, die ganzen APs von diesem Betriebssystem benutzen. Und funktioniert eigentlich recht gut, wenn auch langsam. Das andere Hersteller schon funktionierend gezeigt. Und es ist eigentlich enttäuschend, dass man da nicht weiterentwickelt, dass der Vision irgendwie sagt, es gibt keine Updates. Und das geht halt schon seit Ewigkeiten schon so.
Kann ich das beim Palm und bei Windows CR auch?
Was kennst du da auch?
Updates? Kann ich da auch drin skripten direkt?
Nein, für den IPAC. Windows CR eigentlich nicht. Da hast du die Methode TM, die man da benutzen möchte, ist Visual Studio. Sich von der Microsoft Homebatch runterzuladen und da halt in Visual C oder Visual C++ zu programmieren. Wird ja auch alles möglich zur Verfügung gestellt, aber die Compiler dafür sind räudig bis rottig. Möchte man nicht benutzen, also ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl gehabt, dass der Compiler für den StrongArts, ja also es kann nicht sein, dass man dann noch den Compiler überlisten muss, dass der richtigen Code erzeugt. Das gibt es wie gesagt kostenlos und die einzige Möglichkeit, die Programme dann auf den PDA runterzuladen, ist dieses ActiveSync, was auch nicht der neueste Stand der Technik ist. Naja, den Code runterzuladen funktioniert irgendwie bei jedem dritten Mal nur. Und zuweilen stürzt mir mein Windows dabei auch völlig ab, sogar Windows 2K.
Oh, also es stürzt nicht ab?
Nein, es geht einfach aus.
Also es stürzt jetzt nicht mehr ab, es geht einfach aus.
Es geht einfach aus, mag nicht mehr. So eine Erfahrung, die ich in letzter Zeit gemacht habe. Und was noch so ärgerlich ist, ist, dass für einige Sachen zum Beispiel die Sand-Urs, also der jetzt ist dreifache...
Lassen wir es einfach, oder?
Lassen wir es. Ja, ich habe für den Strong Arm ein bisschen bessere Compiler gesehen. Die sind aber leider nicht dazu fähig, Windows-Applikationen, also Windows-Exen zu erstellen. Aber theoretisch könnte man über den Bild-in-Assembler dort eigene Assembler-Code einbinden, der von anderen Compilern erzeugt worden ist.
032.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Das Wetter. Nachts gering bewölbt oder klar minus 5 bis minus 9 Grad am Tag. Viel Sonne bei 2 bis 5 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Donner.
Der Kastortransport mit Atommüll für das niedersächsische Zwischenlager Gorleben hat am Abend die deutsche Grenze erreicht. Eine halbe Stunde nachdem der Vorzug mit französischen Polizisten angekommen war, fuhr der Transport mit den sechs Spezialbehältern in Lauterburg ein. Im 12 Kilometer entfernten Wörter wurde der Wechsel der Lokomotiven vorgesehen. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat am Abend einen Eilantrag von Kastorgegnern im Zusammenhang mit den Demonstrationsverboten im Wendland abgelehnt. Dies teilte eine Sprecherin in Karlsruhe mit. Zwei Bürgerinitiativen hatten beantragt, auch innerhalb eines Korridors von 50 Metern links und rechts der Transportstrecke demonstrieren zu dürfen. Im Westjordanland ist ein zehn Monate altes israelisches Baby erschossen worden. Nach Angaben des israelischen Rundfunks hat er ein palästinensischer Heckenschütze in Hebron auf den Vater gefeuert, der das Kind in seinen Armen hielt. In Hebron leben einige hundert jüdische Siedler unter mehr als 100.000 Arabern. Amerikanische und russische Sicherheitskräfte haben gemeinsam einen Ring von Kinderpornografiehändlern zerschlagen. Er war von Russland aus über das Internet auf Kundenfang gegangen und hatte Videokassetten in die ganze Welt verschickt. Und Mitteilte wurden in den USA 4 und in Russland 5 Personen festgenommen. Der Verkehr Schwedt auf der B2 wird gebaut. Ihr müsst mit erheblichen Behinderungen rechnen, wenn möglich einfach den Bereich zwischen Kreisverkehr und der Einfahrt zum Gewerbegebiet. Maiden.
Dankeschön.
Ui, tschö.
Also, du willst verreisen.
Am besten mit Freunden.
Gerne auch für 6.000 Mark.
Und am allerliebsten denn eine total tolle Villa irgendwo auf der Welt.
Na dann.
Für 6.000 Mark.
Denn am Samstag ist die weite, wilde Welt ab 14 Uhr zu Gast in der Villa.
Dem legendären Live-Telefon-Chat.
Und wer dabei ist, kann eins von vielen Tidi1-X-Trafex gewinnen.
Oder die Reise von Tui.
Für 6.000 Mark.
In die Villa.
Und übrigens, wer jetzt schon mal in die Villa will, testet www.divilla.de.
Oder wählt mit seinem Tidi1-Handy die 4-88-88.
Gewonnen wird am Samstag ab 14 Uhr.
In der weiten, wilden Welt.
Orbitalist ist im Chaosradio 59. Wir reden über Handhelds und Genja will unbedingt noch was zum Thema Palm-Programmierung sagen.
Also wir hatten ja gerade darüber gesprochen, wie man auf den Geräten selbst programmieren kann. Da wurde über Windows CE gesprochen, da geht das nicht. Auf dem Epoch geht das. Da hat man diese OPL-Sprache und auf dem Palm gibt es da sehr, sehr viele Möglichkeiten. Zum einen gibt es einen Pocket-C-Interpreter, da kann man also lineare C-Programme ganz simpel schreiben, ohne überhaupt sich um die Palm-Sachen zu kümmern. Und hat einfach einen Interpreter, der aus diesen normalen linearen C-Programmen dann ein Palm-Programm macht und das dann auch ausführt. Der Nachteil ist, du brauchst einen Runtime und das Ding ist halt nicht ganz so schnell. Es ist auch kommerziell, das ist ein großer Nachteil. Es gibt eine freie, kostenlose Python-Runtime, also einen Python-Interpreter auf dem Palm. Es gibt ja irgendwie Leute, die finden Python ganz, ganz toll. Die können das also auch direkt in der U-Bahn programmieren. Es gibt die Möglichkeit, ein richtiges, echtes C darauf zu schreiben. Also es gibt einen C-Compiler, der auf dem Palm läuft und einen Ressourcen-Editor, der auf dem Palm läuft. Es gibt also echt Leute, die sich dann hingesetzt haben und gesagt haben, ich programmiere nur noch direkt auf dem Palm. Und da sind auch ganz brauchbare Applikationen aber entstanden, muss ich sagen. Also zum Beispiel gibt es da so einen Encoder für Airbus 64, das ist irgendwie so eine E-Mail-Kodierung, der ist komplett auf dem Palm geschrieben und noch weitere, also irgendwie Kartenspiele und so. Also es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, sich solche Sachen anzugucken, wenn man einen Palm hat und wenn man irgendwie gerade Bus fährt oder so, arbeitet man halt wieder an seinem Projekt rum. Auf jeden Fall lohnt sich das und ist ganz schnell und meistens sogar kostenlos oder preiswert.
Und damit kann man auch so kleine Tools programmieren, wie du hier auf deinem Palm hast. Ist es deiner? Nee, wessen Palm ist es? Genja hat also auf dem Palm etwas, das nennt sich Palm Sutra. Ich vermute, es lehnt anderen Karma Sutra, diese asiatische Poppenkunst. Da stehen dann so Sachen in Genjas Palm Pilot, wie zum Beispiel, in Genjas Palm Pilot stehen die drin. Der Anus wird von einem starken Muskel verschlossen, der das Eindringen schmerzhaft macht, wenn kein Mittel benutzt wird und nicht mit einem Finger und später mit mehreren Fingern vorgedreht wird. Zu häufiger Analverkehr kann dazu führen, dass der, Moment, da muss ich jetzt weiter blättern, dass der Schließmuskel zu sehr gedehnt wird und nicht mehr richtig schließt. Analverkehr kann intensive Orgasmen auslösen, wenn sich die Partner dazu entschließen, ihn zu praktizieren. Ja, ansonsten beim Zugucken. So, das hast du so auf deinem Pard.
Also das ist eine Applikation von vielen.
Ah, das ist mit Büchchen sogar, sehe ich gerade. Nee, ist sehr schön. Also Vorlagen gibt es also auch kostenlos für den Partner. Was hatten wir noch übrig? Was hatten wir denn heute beim Computer Club übrig? Ein... Was war es, Andi? Vermischtes, genau.
Die Bundesregierung hat ja einen Vorstoß gewagt, etwas einzuführen, was es in den USA schon seit Längerem gibt. Zwar gibt es den sogenannten Freedom of Information Act. Und der Freedom of Information Act ist nichts anderes als das Recht eines jeden Bürgers in jede Akte, die der Staat so anlegt, in seinen Behörden, Einsicht zu nehmen. Es sei denn, es gibt besondere Gründe, die und so weiter und so fort. Sicherheit des Landes wissen schon. Aber in der Regel kommt man da ran. Und das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, weil man kann endlich mal gucken, was die Regierung so macht den ganzen Tag. Und allerdings tauchen auch einige Merkwürdigkeiten auf bei solchen Anfragen. Und wenn wir in Deutschland auch noch das eine oder andere erstaunliche herausfinden über unsere Regierung. Da sind wir doch gerade schon bei, oder? Ja, naja, aber wenn man nachgucken kann, was sie wirklich, wirklich getan haben.
Wer weiß, ob das stimmt.
Das sowieso. Und in der aktuellen Datenschleuder abgedruckt ist ein Dokument, das in den USA im Rahmen des Freedom of Information Act zutage gefördert wurde. Und zwar ein CIA-Manual. CIA-Manual. A study of assassination. Definition. Assassination is a term thought to be derived from hashesh, a drug similar to marijuana, said to have been used by Hasan Danzaba to induce motivation in his followers, who were assigned to carry out political and other murders, usually at the cost of their lives. The CIA used to describe the planned killing of a person who is not under the legal jurisdiction of the killer, who is not physically in the hands of the killer, who has been selected by a resistance organization for death and who has been selected by a resistance organization for death and whose death provides positive advantages to that organization. Ja, der Teilsatz ist da zweimal drin, dass das schlecht ist.
Was ich da immer nicht verstehe ist, wenn das von Haschisch kommt, ich weiß nicht, hast du schon mal irgendwie, wenn du breit warst, A den Gedanken verspürt und B überhaupt dir vorstellen können, die Motivation oder die Kraft aufzuwenden, jemanden umzubringen?
Dazu müsste ich ja aufstehen.
Ja, eben.
Und ich meine, ist das schon schlimm genug, irgendwie eine Pringelspackung aufzumachen?
Das ist völlig absurd und interessant, dass die CIA solche Dokumente verfasst. They will also be affected by whether or not the assassin is to be killed with the subject hereafter. Assassinations in which the subject is unaware will be termed simple. Those where the subject is aware but unguarded will be termed chase. Those where the victim is guarded will be termed guarded. If the assassin is to die with the subject, the act will be called lost.
Nachzulesen in der Datenschleuder.
Genau. Und hoffentlich werden wir auch demnächst auf pikante Details über unsere Behördenorganisationen mit Sicherheitsaufgaben.
Über unsere sogenannten Geheimdienste. Chaosradio 59 auf Fritz liegt in den letzten Zügen. Wir haben noch vermischtes, oder?
Ja, also es gibt noch ein paar Termine anzusagen. Das wäre morgen auf der CeBIT um 16 Uhr stand bei Siemens eine Preisverleihung. Siemens wird einen Preis verliehen. Zu was sagen wir noch nicht. Und morgen 16 Uhr Siemens stand Haller 3 auf der CeBIT. Dann hätten wir...
Wenn das so weitergeht verschenke ich mein Siemens-Handy.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Allerdings.
Ja, dann haben wir Mitte Dezember, äh, Mitte April nächsten Monats die Easter Egg zu Ostern.
Ich glaub das wars. Ich glaub es ist diese unangenehme Stadt namens Las Vegas. Richtig, richtig.
Und dann haben wir noch...
Dann haben wir hin genug Hotelzimmer.
Ja, und billige. Und viel Bier.
Ein amerikanisches Bier.
Am 10. Oktober ist dann noch die Hall 2001 in den Niederlanden, Amsterdam.
August. August.
Ja.
Na eigentlich 11. bis 14. aber wenn man am 10. hin fährt, ist schon okay. www.hal2001.org NL Sorry. Sorry.
8 Minuten vor eins, gleich sind wir zu Ende. Zeit für ein Fazit, meine Herren. Ein Personal-Decisive-Fazit.
Fassen wir also zusammen?
Fassen wir zusammen. Jetzt hab ich mir letzte Woche einen Jornada gekauft. War das ein Fehler, hätt ich da noch warten sollen vielleicht?
Naja, drei Monate später sind sie immer alle beliefert.
Ja, das ist klar.
Also ich find ja den Jornada schon nicht schlecht, außer dass die eingebaute Kommunikation fehlt. Na ich möchte, dass da gerne ganze Zeit Internet ist. Also quasi ein Wavelan eingebaut. Eingebautes Wavelan wär nicht schlecht. Und dann natürlich noch flächendeckend Wavelan verfügbar, aber zumindest schon mal GSM. Also das nächste Gerät, was ich mir hole, wird wohl eine Kombination mit Organizer sein, aber dann bitte was, was programmierbar ist und wo am besten Linux draufläuft.
Das hört sich aber nicht so an, als würde es dieses Jahr noch kaufen gehen.
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Dazu möchte ich auch noch mal sagen, nächstes Jahr soll von Sony der neue Palm OS Organizer rauskommen und auf den neuen Palm Organizer von Sony Werbung, Werbung, Werbung, läuft dann irgendwie auch MP3 und kann auch Farbe anzeigen und so.
Die Firma heißt Sony.
Eigentlich ein echt schickes Teil und das möchte man echt haben, aber das kommt halt erst in einem Jahr.
Okay, und von Comva kommt irgendwie demnächst der neue iPack raus, der hat dann schon 32 MB RAM, 64 MB RAM, gibt ein neues Cradle, wo man zwei PCMCA-Karten reinstecken kann, das ist toll, Internet auf der anderen Platte oder Flash, und würde dann sagen, dann lohnt es sich, den neuen iPack zu kaufen, also den alten jetzt nicht mehr kaufen. Der hatte irgendwie noch ein paar Design-Schwierigkeiten gehabt, dass zum Beispiel die Fläche, mit der das Display angeklebt war, das sich teilweise abgelöst hatte und dann hässliche Flecken unter der Folie zu sehen waren, was man nicht haben möchte und dass der Stift dann irgendwann nicht mehr hält im iPack. Und das ist auch ärgerlich.
Also der wird da so reingesteckt und schnappt dann fest.
Genau, das macht der dann nicht mehr. Das kostet ja auch nur 1300 Mark. Das sind halt irgendwie noch Probleme, die bei Geräten, die noch in den Kinderschuhen stecken. Der iPack ist das erste Gerät dieser Serie, wo noch ziemlich viel kommen wird. Und da kann man schon die nächste Serie mit den 64 Megabyte Rappen zuschlagen.
Die Frage vielleicht, was ist der beste? So ein bisschen Evangelisierung.
Lass uns einen Jihad machen.
Ja, also ich würde dazu sagen, ich mag diese Psyon-Teile sehr.
Das macht genau das, was ein PDA machen soll.
Ja, ich bekomme hier gerade einen Palm vorgezeigt. Ich komme da mit der Schriftbedienung, also mit diesem Touchscreen-Schriftzeichen machen gar nicht so klar. Ich mag da lieber eine Tastatur.
Das ist natürlich ein Individuell für jeden verschieden. Dann lass uns doch gleich mal ein bisschen Dieeskalation betreiben. Natürlich kann man sagen, dass jeder PDA halt für eine bestimmte Benutzergruppe faked ist. Zum Beispiel der Z50.
Ja, Z50 von EBM gibt es aber nicht in Deutschland. Den muss man dann wie wie wie Ebay kommen. Jetzt gehen wir mal von einem stinknormalen Holger Klein also quasi. Ich glaube, ich kaufe mir da doch am besten so einen Palm 3, oder? Schon zu alt? Wie heißt denn der jetzt?
Ach so, Entschuldigung. Die neun heißen ja immer im Buchstab und dann drei Zahlen. Also dann würdest du dir einen M505 oder einen M505 kaufen.
Ja, also einen, der nicht aussieht wie ein Schlauchboot, weil da gibt es nämlich dann auch für den schmalen Geldbeutel. Das habe ich nämlich, das fand ich irgendwie praktisch, so ein 50 Marks Adapterkabel, da kann ich jedes stinknormale Modem da dran hängen. Dann hast du zwar irgendwie ein bisschen Kabelage in der Wohnung, aber es funktioniert wirklich sehr gut.
Wenn man sich auch selber löten soll, ein solches Adapterkabel.
Wenn man löten kann, ich habe ja vom stinknormalen Holger Klein geredet.
Das stink ganz normaler Serilierverbindung mit ein paar vertauschten Pins.
Mit ein paar vertauschten was? Ach Pins. Ja ich übe das.
Okay, ich fange da noch an.
Möchtest du noch den Krieg in Zuf üben?
Genau, es soll Linux drauflaufen.
G-Hard.
Na, Linux würde ich da gar nicht so gerne haben wollen, denn es mangelt da irgendwie an allen Ecken und Enden so.
Es gibt einige Linux-Distributionen auch für den IPEC, aber die sind alle noch nicht so ganz toll. Also es gibt einige, die lassen irgendwie noch die PDA-Features vermissen. Andere haben die PDA-Features, ist aber die gesamte GUI auf Java aufgebaut und stürzt deswegen auch fleißig ab. Und ist natürlich ein Ressourcenfresser, sondern gleich irgendwie noch eine Java-VM da drauflaufen zu haben. Aber irgendwann kostet die Rechenzeit genau gar nichts mehr.
Es gibt ja unter Linux aber mittlerweile auch an Alternativen zu Java für die GUI. Es gibt Qt Embedded, was auf Params läuft. Es gibt auch mittlerweile Linux-Resourcen. Und GTK 2.0 befindet sich in Entwicklung. Und da wird es auch einen Fremdwarfer-Treiber vergeben. Und auch Beschleunigungsfunktionen mit Direct-AP, sodass man dann demnächst auch sinnvoll drauf programmieren kann. Und sicherlich werden wir noch schöne Applikationen sehen.
Das war doch ein veritables Schlusswort, oder?
Ja, und dann noch für Leute, die sich sehr für den Palm interessieren, wäre www.palmkonsult.de slash forum. Ein interessantes Forum, wo man eben auch die Basteanleitung bekommt für Holger. Und halt ganz viele schöne Bassereien, Nachrichten, alles Mögliche. Die releasen die Seite in den nächsten Tagen nochmal. Und ich glaube jetzt habe ich die letzten Worte. Treffen vom Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Wer kommen will, ist jeden Donnerstagabend ab 17 Uhr in der Marienstraße, 11 Leerstraße, 18 Uhr. www.ccc.de da nochmal alles nachzulesen.
Genau, das war Chaosradio 59. Vielen Dank Jungs. Sagt alle mal laut Tschüss. Und in drei Minuten, nämlich auf eine Uhr, gibt es hier eine Night Flight. Und der wird heute gemacht von Martin Wettcher. Tschüss, gute Nacht.
Ein Gemeinschaftsprogramm von UAB und SFB.